- Drift people, their thing is stickers.
Unfortunately, one of them I stuck on,
I didn't read what it said and it said
(speaking in foreign language)
or something like that, like...
- Oh my God. (laughing)
- Can you translate that first, Joey?
(upbeat music)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I am your host for today,
the host zone, 'cause,
well, I'll get to that
because with me today is again, the boys.
And once again,
(Joey laughing)
I have another guest with me.
(chuckles)
- We should just like
preface that like every
time Garnt's a host,
just prepare for a guest.
At this point.
(Garnt laughing)
- Oh my God.
So do you want to introduce
yourself to the lovely viewers?
- Okay.
Hello, my name is Alexi Smith,
from the YouTube channel Noriyaro.
- Ooh, nice.
(all clapping)
- He's the drift guy.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- I'm well, one of the drift guys.
I thought I'd reach out to you
after your recent video and-
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- So for anyone who
doesn't know what you do,
do you want to introduce your channel
and kind of what you do on your channel?
- Okay, well, it's
basically about car culture
and drifting in Japan.
People know "Tokyo Drift"
and stuff like that,
but "Initial D" are the two main things.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Cars are popular all over the world
and Japanese cars are popular everywhere,
and this is where they're
from and I enjoy them,
so I came here to do it.
- Nice, nice.
- I think, because you reached out to us,
I think like a month ago or something.
- Yeah.
Well, you obviously, 'cause now
the huge caliber guests that
you could actually get on
this show aren't available, I guess,
'cause they can't come from overseas.
- Yeah.
- So I thought okay, well,
I'm here, I might as well
reach out, 'cause you know-
- Now's my time.
- This is my one chance to do this.
Because I know about cars,
which you've done a little bit of,
and also this sort of culture
and so I really enjoyed Anime and-
- Not gonna lie, when you
did reach out to us like,
I think, 'cause we saw your Twitter post,
I think what was it, like maybe a week?
- It was.
So we recorded our drift video
in the middle of the week,
I believe.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then you were the weekend
right after we recorded,
and we were like, God damn it man.
We were just there
like a week ago.
- We were like shit, man.
I feel so bad.
- And I felt bad,
I knew as soon as we saw that Twitter
and we were having this
video in production
that like the top,
some of the top comments would be,
"Why didn't you invite Noriyaro?"
- "How dare, you did not
get Noriyaro in this video?"
It was the one opportunity
and you messed it up.
- Well, here you go
guys, here you go, he's-
- Look, I knew that we have
a lot of crossover with our viewers
and I knew that at least a
lot of them would enjoy that,
and it could add something
extra to the content
that you already did so
that's why I reached out.
- Yeah.
- Perfect.
Well, thank you very much
for coming on the podcast.
- Thank you for having me, it's great.
- And we now have an actual,
like someone experienced in drifting,
rather than just three idiots
who are trying to drive
manual for the first time,
well, two of us trying
to drive manual and-
- I would like to set the
story straight, gentlemen.
- [Joey] Go on.
- All the comments clowned on me,
said that I broke two cars
and we have a guest here, who is an expert
and actually you know the guy, right?
What was his name?
'Cause we didn't actually get it.
- Oh, you didn't actually, okay,
so the guy that took you for a ride
in the big orange car
with carbon fiber helmet-
- The Drift King.
- The Drift, well, The Drift King.
His name is Naoto Suenaga
and he's one of the two members of,
well, one of a few members of Team Orange,
which is why the car was orange.
- [All] Right, right.
- Team Orange is the team,
which is based at Ebisu Circuit.
The leader of the team
is also the manager of
the circuit as well.
And Naoto Suenaga is one of
the drivers for competition,
and also there's another guy
who drives with him as well.
And they're both doing I think,
the two Team Orange drivers,
one of them is currently in first place
in the National Drifting Competition,
and I think Suenaga's about fifth.
So you were with one of the best drivers.
- [Joey] Yeah, because-
- Arguably in the world.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember
we got a lot of comments
on that video being like,
"Do they not realize who
the Drift King actually is?"
(Garnt laughs)
- No, it was two comments.
It was like,
"Do they not realize the cars
they are drifting in as well?"
Which were apparently
some various special cars.
We knew nothing going into this.
- We were like, "I'll get the
one with the spoiler, please."
(laughing)
All the car enthusiasts just like.
- Anyway, so the guy you got, Naoto,
he's a really cool guy.
You noticed that he was
like laughing and smiling.
- [All] Yeah.
- He's actually like that all the time,
whenever he's drifting.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He's actually one of
the videos on my channel,
it's called a high-speed violent drift.
(all laughing)
Which is based around
entirely his driving.
- I mean, that's the best way to explain
what we went through.
- He's very violent.
- He's very quick, he's very good.
It's like watching Bruce Lee,
like, you know what I'm saying.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it was nuts.
- And you told me that you
were texting him right?
- Just before, yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- And you asked him what
I'd done to the cars?
- Yeah.
- Do you want to explain to the audience
so I can be cleansed of my sins?
- You can be vindicated of...
Okay, so breaking a car in
drifting is not uncommon.
It's obviously-
- That's what I figured, right?
- Yeah.
- It felt pretty easy
to fuck up a car.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, doing what you do in a drift car
is almost the exact opposite
of what people tell you to do
to a car to begin with.
And I think what happened with you was
with the first car,
which was an R33 Skyline-
- Is that special?
- Well, I mean, look,
all the cars that you
drove are not available,
in any other country, apart from Japan.
- Okay.
- Ohm, wow.
- Originally being sold-
- Yeah, I saw a lot of
comments that were jealous
that we were able to drive these cars,
and I didn't know what was so
special about them as well.
- Well, the Skyline, I mean,
people know the Skyline,
the Skyline GT-R, it's
like sort of the apex
Japanese sports car
that people want to get.
So there's that.
You didn't have the
GT-R, you had the GTST.
It's like one step down,
but it's rear-wheel drive, that's why.
The other cars that you drove,
they were both JZX90 Mark
II and JZX100 Mark II.
- Right.
(Garnt laughing)
- That's okay, sorry.
- That's all right, some people
know what I'm talking about.
So what makes those cars special is
the fact that they're
turbo rear-wheel drive,
which means the rear wheels spin
instead of the front wheels.
It's good for drifting.
And those cars have become
very popular recently,
especially overseas because like I said,
they weren't sold overseas,
but in countries like America,
they can import cars that
are over 25 years old.
And those cars are just
coming up to 25 years old now.
So everyone's like, "Oh, I
want to get one of these."
You noticed that the Toyotas
were the last to break.
- Right.
- The Nissan broke first.
Toyotas, anyone who's driven
a Camry or anything like that,
will know they just last forever.
So they're popular.
People are looking
forward to getting them,
so that's sort of why people were hyped.
I actually drive on the same as the,
who drove the white car?
That was you.
- I drove.
- My drift car is the same as that.
- The one that didn't break.
- Yeah, the one that lasted.
- The only one that lasted.
- What was the diagnosis
to the cars that I drove?
- Suenaga said that you
probably broke a coil pack,
which is, it's like part
of the electronics on this,
which is what they said, battery, right?
- Oh.
- It's part of the electronics.
It sits on the engine
and makes the spark that burns the fuel.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- So normally when you drive
a car you're driving forward
and you're not doing burnouts
and spinning the wheels
and stopping, making a lot
of heat and stuff like that.
So that day was very hot,
you probably overheated the coil pack.
So it sits on top of the
engine, which is hot, and-
- Okay, obviously I'm
liking the sound of this.
(Garnt laughing)
- It just got to be too hot
and had to take a lie down for a while.
- So nothing serious.
- Nothing serious though.
- See, I thought I fucked
the clutch or something,
but I don't know if that's the thing-
- It sounded like it.
It made like the worst
sound I'd ever heard,
it was like (imitating car).
- Those cars make weird
noises all the time.
(laughing)
- That's true, yeah.
- Honestly, the first time, if you drive,
like if I jump in someone
else's drift car and like,
just even drive it around,
you have to spend the
first five minutes going,
"Okay, that's a normal noise.
That's a normal noise."
(all laughing)
- Figuring out which noises are okay.
- Usually the way it works is,
if something smells different
or sounds dramatically different
then you probably have
a problem after that.
- All right, that makes sense.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I remember when we first
got into the cars for the first time,
I mean, they were stripped bare.
I'd never been in a car like that
that was just specifically
designed for one purpose,
and that was for drifting, you know?
And it felt like when I
was turning on the engine,
it was like coughing.
It was like (coughing).
And I was like, is this normal?
But it sounded like
and it felt like these
cars had gone through
a hell of a beating,
which is what I guess
they're designed for.
- They're for the school,
for the Team Orange school,
which is what you did,
I've actually been, in the
past, been an assistant teacher,
like a translator for like the-
- English?
- Yeah, in English
for some of the higher level.
- Oh, wow.
- This is a while ago though.
We had a guy who was
like an investment banker
for Barclays Bank or something like that.
He had Ferrari's back home in England
and before he was being sent back home,
back to his home office
from the Japan office,
he'd been asked by his secretary,
"Is there anything
you'd like to do before,
something we'd like to do?"
He said, "Oh, I'd like to try drifting."
So they set all this up
and they sent him there on the train,
I had to go pick him up.
- A lot of money.
- Yeah, I was like,
"Oh, this is like super
high level guests."
And he thoroughly enjoyed it.
So, we have all sorts of people.
And so those cars have
been through a lot of-
- I'd figured that those cars were,
they were a car,
but I just assumed they
were all bits and pieces
that have been repaired and
repaired and repaired, right?
Can you even call it the
car at that point, right?
Isn't that like a philosophy
question where it's like-
- The farmer's ax or the ship of Theseus?
- Yeah, the ship of Theseus, right.
- I mean, I've seen, at least the Skyline,
I've seen it personally go
through two clutches before.
- I mean, when they even opened the thing,
all of the parts look like
completely different ages.
Yeah, it looked like a timeline.
- It looked like a Lego,
like thing that your five year old makes
out with a bucket of Legos
when none of the pieces fit together.
It's like, I mean, it's
a piece of work, I guess.
- Yeah.
I mean, those cars are all, unfortunately,
all the best drift cars are
starting to get quite old.
They're all from like 20, 30 years ago.
And you have to start taking your,
you'll have like some people
will buy, if they have space,
who'll buy like two or
three of these cars,
you have them at the back,
something breaks, you take
a part or you smash it,
you cut off the metal and weld
it onto the car and fix it.
So, yeah, they're all like that.
It's unique.
You can't love a drift car.
You can love like the, you can have like,
this is kind of esoteric,
but a drift car will have its own spirit.
- Right.
- But it's not related to
the body of the car itself.
- The ghost of the drift.
(laughing)
- Yeah, you might have
to change the engine,
you have to change the-
- Right.
- It's basically all
parts getting changed.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And so that's one car that I fucked,
but it wasn't my fault in the end.
Thank you, thank you.
Now, the second car.
What was the second car?
- My car.
- He didn't get back to me about that one
so I don't know.
- So you probably did fuck that car.
- You still fucked my car up.
- But you gave me a theory
off the podcast saying
that he reckons it's all the stalling
that somebody did to it,
that might've fucked it.
- So on--
(Connor laughing)
- Please tell, please tell, I'm-
- Please, I beg of you.
(laughs)
- So I'm assuming that you edited out
most of the stalling you did,
it's like there's a lot
more than what actually-
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I stalled a lot in that video,
but that was probably maybe like a third
of the amount that I actually stalled.
- We could probably make
like an hour special,
just on Joey's stalling by himself.
But to explain to our audio-only listeners
that probably didn't
see the drifting videos,
so we made a drift special, where-
- You should definitely go watch.
Get off whatever platform you are.
Go on YouTube.
- Get on YouTube.
- And yeah, we made a
drift special where we try
to learn drifting for the
first time ever, basically.
This was our first-
- Yes, tried like
underline, bold letters try.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I didn't break two cars.
- [Garnt And Joey] You
absolutely broke two cars.
- But I guess for our listeners,
who know nothing about drifting,
know nothing about car culture,
do you want to explain
like what drift culture is,
especially in Japan,
in like layman's terms?
- Okay well, drifting is,
if you've never done it before,
is like most people who've driven a car,
well, these days cars have a
lot of safety features on them.
They have antilock brakes
and stability control
and all this sort of stuff
which sort of protects you
a little bit from making
too much of a mistake.
But everybody who has lived
somewhere where it rains a lot,
or it snows or something like that,
has had a moment where
you've gone around a corner
or like a roundabout or something,
where the car has just sort of
going like this or like that.
And you're like ah!
You get that crunch in your stomach.
You're like, ah, that's not right!
- Yeah.
- That's the feeling we're
going for the whole time.
(all laughing)
The feeling of like the out of, I mean,
I think they said that in "Tokyo Drift",
it's like you gotta be out of control
to be in control, whatever.
(Garnt laughing)
- Damn.
- It's that feeling of being on the edge.
It's like surfing or skiing.
It's like you're not
gripping what you're on,
you're sliding across it
and it's that being on the
razor edge of that slide,
which is just so much fun.
Not everybody thinks it's fun.
Some people do.
The same thing, some people love surfing,
some people love skiing or
ice skating or whatever.
Any of those sorts of
things where it's like
something to do with that.
You can enjoy it, like that's not for me.
But then some people just get
a massive rush and that feeling.
- It was so fun.
- Yeah, it was a lot of fun.
I remember experiencing the
drift taxi for the first time.
I remember having the
conversation with Joey,
which we didn't record,
but Joey was telling me how
it felt like the afterglow after sex
is what you described it as.
- I was metaphorically rock-hard.
I was like, damn dude,
that's fucking awesome.
- I was like damn,
how am I ever gonna get an erection again
after experiencing that?
(laughing)
- Some of the most chill
I've ever been in my life is
driving back from a track day-
- Which was so nice.
- At like nine o'clock at night,
I'm on the expressway,
just cruising along,
going back home, It's like a cool breeze
and it's just like.
- Yeah, every single organ in your body,
which can release some sort of chemical,
enjoyment chemical-
- It's just like ah!
- It does that, it honestly does that.
I've had times when I first moved here
and I remember I bought the car,
got the stuff, finally got to track day
and this one particular corner, I hit it,
it was a big long, third gear corner,
and I literally yelled out,
"This is why I came to Japan!"
(all laughing)
It was that feeling, it was like,
I was looking for that.
- Yeah.
He found his life purpose
going around a corner.
- Yeah, it's just really enjoyable.
- One thing I wondered
when I was doing it,
I was like how the fuck
do you get into this?
- That's what I was gonna ask as well.
- You know like you said,
like skiing and stuff like that,
even that is like,
I think a lot of people think skiing
is kind of hard to get
into, and snowboarding.
It's not really, you
just go to a mountain,
you do the week long-
- You just try it out.
- And you get into it, right?
It's not that difficult.
But with drifting,
it seems like there's
a lot more commitment
and also it's just way harder to get into
'cause when we tried to
do the drifting video,
they initially wanted us to buy a car.
We were like,
"Well, the fuck are we gonna do
with the car after we're done?"
Right? They were like,
"We can sell it back."
I'm like, "I don't wanna
fucking go through that."
That sounds like a pain, but you know,
even you can rent skis,
you can rent snowboards.
How do you take that first leap
to getting into drifting?
And also, especially if
you have no background,
because those people at the track,
are like the kids who've worked there,
I mean they were like 17
teaching us, which is insane but,
they'd obviously grown up with it.
But how does someone who
came from investment banking,
get into, obviously he
has so much money but-
- Which is one of the things
you'll probably need is money,
which is the biggest
thing I just found out.
- I didn't notice that.
- Even just one day of drifting for us
where some of us barely
learned anything, I feel,
still cost a lot of money.
- Yeah.
- So how do you get into it?
How do you take that original leap
and how do you know you wanna do it?
- The pattern most people take, I mean,
when I started at least,
is you start with your daily driver,
you have some sort of car which can drift
and you just try and make sure
it doesn't break too much.
- Okay.
- I mean, let's be frank.
Most people start off on the street,
some quiet street somewhere.
I mean, that's what most-
- Like a parking lot or something?
- Like a parking lot or
in the case of Australia,
like an industrial area or like
some sort of mountain road,
so like a windy road somewhere,
where you just go,
you'll sit there for a few minutes
and okay, there's no
one coming up behind me.
There's no traffic, okay, let's go.
And you do a little lap or something
or you go with friends and
spotters and things like that.
So there's that.
The best way is to go to a circuit.
What got me, when I started
to understand the feeling was
I had an RX7 back when I was like 18,
I'd go to the track and drive around.
It was all very like, oh
yes, you know, grip driving
and getting good times and breaking points
and clipping points
and this sort of stuff.
I'm like this is kind of boring.
It's just kinda like doing the
same thing again and again.
But then I'd come in a bit too hot
and break too late and the back of the car
would sort of step out like, "Oh, yes.
Dude, that was sick.
I'll do that again."
Try and like come out of the corner,
if you come out of a corner,
you press the accelerator really hard,
I mean, look, it's like video
games do the same thing.
Mario Kart, whatever.
(all laughing)
It's like you do something
and the back of the car slides out.
And I'd do that, but then you
have the flag masters like,
"Don't drift, that's da, da."
And they get all annoyed at you.
So we started a little club in Australia,
in Sydney, where I'm from-
- Sydney represent.
- Sydney!
And we have track days
and we just go out there
and you just do it,
like you just try.
We'd watch these Japanese videos
and these weird videos
where they're talking,
I can't understand what they're saying,
but it's like, "Yeah,
okay, we'll try that."
- "I can't understand what they're saying,
but they're pulling some sick drifts."
- Basically, yeah.
The best thing these days
is it's so accessible now.
Like these days you can,
there's millions of videos and everything
and you can just get into super easy.
- And you're one of them, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I feel like no amount of
videos could prepare me.
- I actually tried to, before
the day of the Drift Circuit,
I actually tried to watch like
a basic how To drift video.
Fucking didn't help any, by the way
'cause there's no like,
you can read up about it
and learn about it all you want,
but there's a different
feeling where you have to like,
when you're just in this car seat
and in the moment and
you just have to like,
you kind of have to feel your way through.
- Yeah, it's a massive
seat-of-the-pants thing,
where you're trying to
unlearn what you already know.
Like if you're already a regular driver,
everything is the exact opposite
of what you should be doing.
You're not supposed to rev the engine.
You're not supposed to dump the clutch.
You're not supposed to spin the wheels.
You're not supposed to slide around.
You're not supposed to
do any of that stuff.
So it's the Yoda,
"You must unlearn what you have learned."
To start off with.
(all laughing)
And that can be a bit of
a hurdle for some people
and for other people who maybe
have a bit more of a feel for it,
then it's a bit,
you get over that hump a bit faster.
But honestly, look, anybody can do it.
It's not an unusual skill
to be able to drift.
- I mean, yeah, I managed
to somewhat pull it off
at the end of the day
and yet I went into it
not knowing how to drive
a manual at all, right?
- Yeah.
It's not an unusual skill,
but the gap is obviously, as you said,
the commitment to keep
doing it is a huge thing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, because I mean,
shouldn't you have to buy a car
dedicated to drift?
You can't just, do people use
their like daily commuter car?
- Yeah, yeah.
- They do?
- Some, well, I-
- Can they drift?
- Yeah.
- Oh okay.
- You don't need a crazy
car to be able to drift.
You need some like minor modifications.
But generally any rear-wheel drive car
can drift reasonably easy.
And the downside is though
like if you have to go to work
on a Monday morning and you
broke something on, you know?
- I was gonna say.
- I've done that too,
like I've broken a gearbox
at the track and I'll have
to go to work on the Monday.
And it's like, well, I've
only got like first, second
and fifth gears.
Okay, it's like (imitating
shifting gears).
(all laughing)
I'd be like, "Just go
around me, I can't..."
(all laughing)
So there's that.
But you know, these days,
people will have dedicated track cars,
but that adds a whole
extra level of money.
- 'Cause I noticed when we were at Ebisu,
there was so many
foreigner-friendly staff,
and it was like, "Come buy a
car, just come drift here."
- Yeah.
- So the thing about Ebisu
is Ebisu is very special.
Ebisu is probably one of
the, if Ebisu didn't exist,
that'd be one less reason for
me to originally move here.
- Right.
- So it's been around for a long time?
- A long time.
- Ebisu is the track
that we are drifting on
in case you don't know.
- Yeah, Ebisu Circuit up in Fukushima.
What makes it special
is it's drift friendly,
it has not one track,
but many tracks with different styles.
It's about seven, yeah, I mean,
well, there's some like open
skid pans and stuff like that.
They're all different kinds of tracks.
A lot of very famous drift videos,
like you watch a famous drift video,
oh, that's where it was.
Especially the, you guys didn't go to it.
There's a track called Minami,
the South Circuit,
which is infamous for
being extremely difficult
and extremely rewarding to drive.
It's extremely dangerous.
I've seen it break legs and
ribs from people crashing there.
I saw a guy right off
his car, an American guy,
on his second lap.
He bought the car there-
- No.
- Second lap he went over the entry
and just went straight into the wall,
banana the front end, done.
(laughing)
- Have you ever had any bad injuries
or have you ever had any bad
crashes or anything like that?
- Knock on wood, no.
But you shouldn't ask
the person who drive cars
that sort of question.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God, what an asshole.
- I'm sorry.
- Yeah, a lot of these
small crashes, but I mean,
that sort of comes with it,
but yeah, personally I've seen,
actually there has been
some very severe injuries
at Ebisu Circuit from-
- I can imagine.
- I can only imagine.
- It comes with the sport, right?
- Yeah, motorsport, yeah,
it can be quite sketchy.
I mean, it used to be a lot better
because the speeds were lower
and people weren't quite as extreme now,
but now everyone's just going
flat out the whole time.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's terrifying.
- Car rolling over and yeah.
- Okay, here's a question
I want to ask though.
As someone who like is into
the drift scene, obviously,
"Initial D", legit or no?
- Okay, uh...
(Garnt laughing)
- 'Cause I've always wanted to know.
'Cause the "Initial D" is
kind of put on this pedestal
of like, yes, this is the drift anime.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And even though there's other ones,
like "Wangan Midnight" and like
all these other great ones,
it's always like "Initial D" is like
the cream of the crop, right?
- [Alexi] Yeah.
- So I want to know like as
someone who's into that scene
and who's probably watched
a lot of "Initial D"-
- I've seen all of it.
- Yeah.
Legit or not legit?
- Okay.
That is like, sort of saying like,
okay, it's like saying someone who is like
into computers saying,
"Is "Hackers", is that
what it's actually like?"
(all laughing)
Wait, wait, wait.
Or someone who's into surfing like,
"Oh, is "Point Break", is
that what it's actually like?"
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- It's like, yes, it's
based a lot on reality.
Obviously there's a lot of dramatization,
but honestly "Initial D" is pretty good
as far as that sort of stuff is concerned.
Now, so going all the
way back to the start,
the Mangaka, Shuichi
Shigeno, who wrote that,
his specialty is sort of like
teenage, romantic, drama
and motorsports sort of thing.
(Garnt laughs)
- A classic combination.
- I don't know,
I guess it's like a sort of
a 1990s Japan sort of thing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He's done other one's
like, "Baribari Densetsu",
which is based around motorcycle racing.
- Oh, okay.
- Oh.
- That was also an anime as well.
There was another one, I forget,
something, something, blue sky,
I forget the name of it,
which was like the
precursor to "Initial D"
where like the main
character drove an AE86,
you know and-
- That's the main car in "Initial D"-
- Yeah, that's he main car in "Initial D."
And it was set at like some
sort of rich kids summer
tennis camp or something
like that, I don't know.
- Right.
- Drifting around the tennis court.
- Well, there was some
sort of thing with like,
I don't know, anyway.
So then came out "Initial D."
So yes, it's mostly true
because back then in
the late 80s, early 90s
if you went up to the
mountains in Gunma, Saitama,
anywhere around Tokyo, you'd find dudes
in these little, cheap, rear-wheel
drive Corollas or Silvias
or things like that, just having fun.
Sliding around,
enjoying a Saturday night.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- And at the same time too,
yes, there were races done up there.
I've spoken to, see,
this is one of those
things where the reality
is almost better than the fiction.
- Right.
- Oh, okay.
- I've spoken to people,
I've actually met the real,
Takumi Fujiwara, the real guy.
- The guy who inspired
the, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There's a guy, he worked at a tofu shop
and he would deliver the tofu up
to the top of the mountain or some stuff
so it's all based on reality.
- So cool.
- Like there's one guy I know,
I did a job with him once,
where he's a Gymkhana champion of Japan,
Gymkhana is where you...
It's like what you did with the cones.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right.
- Where you've got to drive
around as fast as possible.
- Like an obstacle course.
- Yeah, you got to remember it too.
It's like, you going to go four,
then backwards here and around
this three times and back.
It's very complicated.
- I'm sure it's a bit more
complicated than what we did.
(all laughing)
- And so, he's like one
of the Japanese champions
and I was talking to him about,
yeah, we used to go out
to this certain mountain,
I had a CRX out there
and I was the fastest guy on the mountain.
And then one day these guys
showed up with a bunch of Civics
and they were faster than me.
And I was like, "Oh, I
need to beat these guys."
And we had races, and it was like,
this sounds exactly like "Initial D."
- Sounds like a little gang war going on.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's the same thing.
And all the stuff you've
seen in initial D,
like for example, there's
a scene in that where
a bunch of gangsters
come up the mountain to,
like one of the other street racers calls
a bunch of gang members
to come up to fight.
- [Connor] Of course.
- Yeah.
- And then they all see the Takashi
and they're like, "Oh, senpai."
(all laughing)
That's real, guys would,
see, this is the thing about,
'cause it's street racing, it's not legal.
- Right.
- So, guys who are out to look for fights
would actually go up there
and like try to start fights
with street races and stuff.
So all these little points you see in that
are based on some sort of reality.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- That's pretty cool.
- So it's pretty good.
They talk about the
different kinds of cars,
their strengths and weaknesses
and like some cars on certain
touge and stuff like that.
There's the one with the spiral GTR,
which loses its brakes going down a hill
and the other two cars
that have to go in front,
like, stop it with...
Like that, I know someone
who had to do that,
in real life.
- Oh my God.
- That's so cool.
- I was watching your videos,
and I saw there was just like, an AE-
- AE86.
- AE86 like meetup.
Like in the place where,
and it was fucking tons of them.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That was so cool.
- Yeah.
So I guess fortunately or unfortunately,
I guess it's one of the
things that made me confident
to reach out to you guys was
some of my most popular
videos on my YouTube channel
are based around "Initial D."
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- And anime culture as well.
Well, yeah, it's...
I mean, if you think about it,
it's just a very expensive cosplay.
(all laughs)
- It's a car cosplay.
- It's like a weapon, but-
- Yeah, at that show,
there was the main characters,
you know, Corolla,
there was the Takahashi brothers RX7s.
Even the new Manga that's out now,
what's it called?
Ghost, "MF ghost."
Made by the same, the new 86
with the number on the door.
People do cosplays of
these like car cosplays.
- It's cosplay with attitude.
That's what it is.
- And I noticed that even like
the Japanese people knew you,
and were like fans of you.
- Uh, yeah, I mean-
- It's because you just like
'cause you go to these events so often
you're kind of like notorious.
- I go to all these events also,
a lot of my videos that I
know are gonna be popular
with Japanese people, I have
subtitles on them as well.
- Oh, okay.
- They watch them.
There's not a lot of car content
being like car YouTubers in Japan.
I mean there are, but I think
people often say like I've,
'cause I'm looking at it
from a different perspective.
I'm like, oh look, it's
the "Initial D" car.
'Cause if a Japanese person does it,
it's kind of cringy I guess, to them?
- Yeah.
It's a little weird how they are like that
with kind of anime.
- Their own, yeah.
- Yeah,
like stuff that is a reference to an anime
and it's like, oh yeah, this
is "Initial D" thing, I get.
Anyway, whatever.
It's like dude, it's like be proud of it.
- [Alexi] Yeah, yeah.
- It's fucking "Initial D", it's cool.
- I guess for me,
drifting has always been so
ingrained in Japanese culture
and Japanese car culture,
because if it wasn't for
stuff like "Initial D"
or like "Tokyo Drift",
I would have no idea about drifting.
- Memes aside about "Tokyo Drift",
it is legit the only reason
I knew that Japan was famous for as a kid.
I can see you dying inside.
- Talking to you about the
international drift scene,
I'm gonna be honest.
I had no idea there was an
international drift scene.
I thought it was like all Japan
and everyone was following that.
- It used to be like that.
- Right.
- I mean, nowadays,
okay, so I've sort of come
to peace with "Initial D"
and "Fast and Furious"
and that sort of stuff.
Look, it's like anything where
like you're into something
and there's a movie about it
and people go, "Oh
yeah, I saw that movie."
Like, "It's not like that."
(all laughing)
But the fact that it
makes it, it's an easy,
it's a wedge to open a conversation.
People sort of understand that.
It's like okay, yeah, I'm fine with it.
It's the same thing with "Tokyo Drift."
The majority of that,
I mean, you can probably look
at the Japan side of and go,
"No, that's not actually
what it's like here."
But it is in certain ways.
But people don't drift in car parks.
- I was gonna say, that seemed
just very irresponsible.
- Yeah.
I mean, if you're gonna
see drifting in Tokyo,
it's gonna be like down on the docks,
in like the big open
areas where trucks go.
- Like "Wangan Midnight", for example.
- Yeah.
- I think they had a scene in
"Tokyo Drift" at the docks.
I'm pretty sure they did.
- They did, they actually did, yeah.
- I did my research of this episode.
- I couldn't get over the
car park scene though,
because like looking,
'cause you go into any car
park in like Tokyo or whatever,
like you can barely drive-
- It's like the fucking Daihatsu boxes,
can barely get through
and then you're like, what the fuck?
- That's probably the most
inaccurate thing about that.
But the rest of it like,
the general theme of
what they talk about is-
- Do you like the movie?
- Uh.
(all laughing)
- That's a loaded question.
- Honestly, I think I
would genuinely like it,
the movie for its campiness
if the main actor wasn't so fucking awful.
- Yeah.
- Fucking can't stand his accent.
- Every time he speaks
Japanese I do cringe.
- [Garnt] Oh yeah, right.
- It's so bad.
- There's a scene that has
been cut out of the movie
where they steal a bunch of
tires from a petrol station
and it's got what's the guy's?
Little, little, no, Little Dog Snoop.
What's the character's name?
The actual actor.
- Nate Dogg?
- No, no, no.
The guy in the movie-
- His like side kick?
- His side kick character.
- I know he's a rapper, right?
- Yeah, he's a rapper.
Anyway-
- It'll be on screen.
- There's a scene where
he distracts the staff,
by like speak by,
he opens a drink 'cause
it doesn't have any fizz
and he's like (speaking
in foreign language).
(all laughing)
It's just so...
(speaking in foreign language)
Like it's just so bad.
Oh, man that's so bad.
But look, it's fine.
Like I said, I've come to peace with it.
Like you said, it's horrible campiness,
but it is a good general overview.
And there are some scenes
where they kind of get into
the side of where it's kind of like
escaping from reality and free.
'Cause honestly it is like that.
Like you go up to the
mountains at two in the morning
and all you can hear is like
the sound of the crickets
and maybe a river nearby and that's it.
And then all of a sudden
you hear this screaming
coming from the distance
and it's a bunch of cars
and the headlights shining through
the trees and they come through there.
It is very cool.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Right.
- I've seen footage of like
the late night drifting stuff
and it's like, there's a
part of me that's like,
"Oh man, that'd be so cool to be in."
But then at the same time,
I'm like, "No."
- So dangerous.
- I like my life.
You know what I mean?
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- Basically what I'm
getting out of this is like,
"Initial D" isn't realistic enough.
(laughing)
Compared to "Tokyo Drift."
- Look man, I think, again,
the reality of all this stuff.
It's same thing with
the "Wangan Midnight",
the freeway racing,
like the stories that I've heard.
See, a lot of those guys don't
want to talk about it too,
'cause they just want to keep it
buried in the past and stuff,
but when you can get them talking,
like if they've been
drinking and stuff like that,
like you're just sitting there going,
"Wow, holy shit.
How are you still alive?
Wow."
It's so cool.
It's like a lot of stuff like in Japan too
where you get here and
you meet these people.
Same thing with this industry too.
It's like you meet them
and you hear what they did
and stuff they've done, it's like-
- I almost feel like because
of how the culture is
and how strict everything is,
I've met like the craziest
fucking people here,
that just do not give a
fuck and they're like,
"All right, this is what I used to do."
And I feel like I've never
met anyone like this in the UK
because everyone's kind of like,
"I don't really care about the rules."
But when you get a
society that's so strict
that normally you get characters.
- And you hear some of
the craziest stories
that you don't normally hear about.
And you really have to
drag it out of them.
You know what I mean?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- They'll just mention like this offhand
or off the cuff thing, you're like-
- Yeah, they'll just say
something and you're like what?
- Please elaborate.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
So you were mentioning that
you know "Initial D" very well
and all that anime, but I'm curious,
do you know actually any other anime,
or are you into any other anime?
- You are in an anime podcast.
- Okay, so the...
- Anime podcast.
- One of the things that
made me a bit more confident
to reach out to you guys was that
I used to be massively
like into anime a lot.
- Hell yeah.
- How long ago are we talking?
- Okay, so it's 2020 now,
I was in probably like
middle school, high school.
So we're talking like 1994,
I'd say was 92, 93, 94-
- Fuck, you were in high
school before I was born.
(group laughs)
- I was two years old.
- This is the era of VHS rental tapes.
- [Connor] Right, right, of course.
- And just going forward,
people, you know, IRC list serves
and stuff like downloading random,
getting throttled,
downloading too much stuff,
swapping CDs and things like that.
- Burning CDs.
- So, how did you get anime back then?
How does one get into anime back then?
What was like the entry point?
- Oh well, most people say
like, "Oh yeah, I saw,"
what was the actual name for Macross?
"Robotech."
- "Robotech."
- Thins like that.
So every time I would see,
and this sort of, I watched
the podcast with with Chris
when he talked about this sort of thing,
where just every time you
see something from Japan,
there was just something about it
that just kind of resonated.
- Yeah.
- Okay,
you know what I'm talking about.
You just sat like, "Yeah,
this is my aesthetic.
I like this."
- Yeah.
- So every time I saw and
sometimes you don't realize
what it is and you're like,
"Oh, that was actually a Japanese anime."
Right.
Or like, even stuff
like "Inspector Gadget",
which was, it was a French,
all those French-Japanese
productions back then.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
Just something about it because
it was animated in Japan.
- Yeah.
- And slowly, slowly, it
just starts to be like,
you see this tape at the Civic Video,
which is my local rental shop,
and like, "What is this crazy
looking things rated R18?"
(all laughing)
Oh and you take it to the counter like...
'Cause they don't care, it's like,
oh, it's just some
animation, yeah, whatever
like that changes it.
It's like "Wicked City"
and things like that.
- Oh.
- Oh,
I freaking love "Wicked City", dude.
- So you got into anime
during the fucking 80s,
90s OVA boom manga?
- The manga VHS era.
- Oh my God.
- It was amazing. Everything.
I'd just go there and rent that stuff
and it just went from there to-
- That was kind of like a
golden age in and of itself.
- Yeah because it was
like everything you could,
anime was so brutal back then.
Everything was "Devilman Crybaby."
- Pretty much.
- You know what I mean?
- Like "Wicked City"," Ninja Scroll."
- "Vampire Hunter."
- "Violence Jack" like shit like that.
It was just like so fucked up,
but it was so good.
- "Cyber City Oedo 808."
- Yeah, yeah.
- "Akira."
So I'm actually wearing,
this is my "Akira" shirt.
- [Joey] That's such a
sick "Akira" shirt too.
- So this is about 20 something years old.
I just thought I'd wear it
here today.
- Oh, wow.
- Although again, "Akira"
all that sort of stuff,
it just like blows your mind.
Like oh, this is so cool,
and it was just always enjoyable.
Any sort of media can
just get your hands on.
Back then like, the UK video
game magazines were very good
with that sort of thing like they'd-
- Were they?
- You don't know about that?
- No.
- So, there was,
from what I can tell
there was a huge imports.
Like Gray Import scene back
in the day for video games.
So people would, they'd be playing
like Japanese stuff all the time.
And these certain video game magazines
they'd feature a lot of Japanese content.
- I do remember roughly
having some memory of seeing
a lot of Japanese stuff growing up,
which is why I think
eventually I did get into it
because I always thought like you said,
every time you see it you're like,
"Man, that's really fucking cool."
It always just happened
to be Japanese stuff.
That was always the thing
that stuck out to me.
- [Alexi] Yeah.
- So was it like a Nintendo Power,
but not a legit Nintendo Power?
- We had a lot of those in the UK-
- Yeah, there were a lot of,
I forget what it was called.
"Hyper", it was called "Hyper."
- That sounds familiar.
- Yeah,
I'm pretty sure it was a
magazine called "Hyper"
and I've managed to find
a big download dump of it
a while ago like every issue scanned.
And I was like, "Oh yeah,
I remember this stuff."
(laughing)
- Gaming publications in the UK
and stuff like that were
huge for a very long time.
- CV&G or whatever it was called, "CVG."
- I can't remember, but I
remember there was just like,
everyone had demo disks
from the magazines.
- Oh, I remember those days,
the PS1 demo discs that you
get with the free magazine.
- We had that in Australia too.
- We did have that.
And just stuff would be,
there'd be like some sort of
video game where you'd see it
and it's like, you'd find out later, like,
oh, that was actually a real,
it was like a Japanese game.
That particular sort of thing, right?
So, and it snowballed from there.
I didn't have any
friends who were into it-
- Same, same.
- My school, nobody.
Not even, maybe like
one kid from Hong Kong,
who like kind of liked "Dragonball."
(all laughing)
- Why is it always "Dragon Ball"?
- Yeah, so you have like some of those
little cards, whatever.
- Yeah.
- And it got to the point
where it's things like
going to specialty shops and ordering,
see, I remember I bought the,
when "Evangelion" came
out, like the movie,
I ordered the VHS tape,
'cause it first came in
on VHS, no subtitles.
I wanted the best, the highest quality
and I downloaded the script.
(Connor laughs)
- You're like reading along.
- So my original
experience of the Eva movie
was sitting there going-
- Oh my God.
- You were fan subbing yourself.
- I would say yeah.
- You were live fan subbing "Evangelion."
That's crazy.
- Oh my God.
- Dude, I swear, I feel that,
but this is embarrassing.
When I watched fucking
Shakespeare in the Globe Theater,
I couldn't fucking understand a word.
(all laughing)
Because they talk in
like a older version of,
I don't know what type
of English it's called.
- Ye old speak.
- Ye old English.
- I was like fucking online,
like following the story.
I'm like, "Oh, this is that part, oh."
I couldn't understand a fucking thing.
But obviously yours is a
lot more understandable.
- No, same thing, but you get it.
Unfortunately, there's
that one scene where,
can I spoil it or not?
Is it old enough?
- Spoiler alert.
Oh so, it's fucking Eva.
Why haven't you watched Eva yet?
- Where Oscar gets
stabbed through the head
and they're ripped apart,
I accidentally read that too early.
(all laughs)
And she's one of my favorite characters,
and like Eva gets violently ripped apart,
I'm like, "Ah, what!"
And then they all die like, ah!
I remember feeling, it was
like two in the morning
and I remember feeling sick.
I was like, "Oh my God."
Yeah, it was a thing, man, like yeah.
So it just-
- That was a brutal scene too.
- Yeah, so it went from there then-
- I love how you spoiled
yourself on a script.
(all laughing)
- I feel old when I talk
about hard-coded fan subs,
you know what I mean?
- [Joey] Yeah, right.
- And then now we're talking about,
fuck hard-coded fan subs.
How about on paper,
printed paper fans subs?
(laughing)
- So you printed out
like 25 sheets of paper.
- It was about that thick.
- Oh my God.
- Did they have like translated notes
and everything too, like-
- No and it was pretty good.
- Keikaku means plan.
(all laughing)
- It was pretty good.
It was designed for people to read,
like to read and watch.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- They type set it pretty well.
Yeah, I downloaded off like some,
something like some weird website.
- So you're like more of an
OG anime fan than any of us.
- Dude, we do things like
where we'd swap VHS tapes.
Like what you do is watch-
- Yeah, I've heard about that.
- Yeah you'd have your
list of all your content,
you'd have that somewhere,
and then people you're
friends with, they'd say,
"Hey, I want that.
What do you want from mine?"
And you'd make a copy of the
tape and send it to each other.
- Oh my God.
(Joey laughing)
- That sounds so fun though.
- I want ask, 'cause like growing up,
we had the problem of like
our anime was for example,
on YouTube, and sometimes
there would be like
an episode or a part of an
episode that wasn't uploaded.
What was it like for you,
where you had to actually
get physical VHS tapes?
Did you have to like watch
anime episodes out of order,
or if some episodes were available,
you just get them anyway?
- I think it was,
I mean, because the thing
about that is it's much easier
to delete things so that's why,
like something would be
a copywriter or whatever.
someone's channel would go down.
But back then, everybody
had like physical media,
so it all like exists.
Like it's not gonna disappear.
- So as long as you didn't
lose the physical tape.
- Yeah, as long as you had
it, it's like it's there
and you know that someone else has it.
They can just make a
copy and send it to you.
- Physically?
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- And people would be very,
goes back then people
like hardcore into it
so they'd have a complete collection.
That wasn't really an issue, no.
If wanted to see something,
you could get it.
- Was it expensive?
- Oh man, I don't even
know how much I've spent-
- Yeah, right?
- People out here complaining about
a $6 monthly subscription.
(all laughing)
- Yeah.
- If I could pay that six bucks
a month back then for
almost unlimited content,
wow.
- Yeah.
- So stop complaining Zoomers!
- So how much did you have to pay for like
a single VHS tape then?
Or like if you wanted to
watch an anime, a series,
what would that cost?
- Okay, so the best thing was
when the Australian
distributors like Madman
and stuff started to make,
'cause the Japanese disks would have like,
two or three episodes a disk.
And it'd be like $60.
- Yeah.
- What?
- It's like that to this day as well.
- It is. Right, I just don't get it.
Whereas overseas,
that's the best thing like in
America and other countries
where they make-
- A whole season.
- Yeah, the whole season on one thing.
It's like that's how it should be.
- [Joey] Right.
- And it's still good quality
and subtitled and everything.
So, yeah, but I didn't really
spend money on anything else.
I didn't go out.
(all laughing)
- Are you into drugs, son? No, anime.
- I didn't go drinking,
didn't do do anything,
that sort of stuff, I watched anime and-
- You went from one expensive
hobby to another man.
(laughs)
- So that makes me
curious then, how did you,
because obviously I've
seen your videos as well,
you can speak Japanese,
like much better than
me and Garnt like 100%.
How did you, were you learning Japanese
before you moved to Japan,
and also when did you move to Japan,
and what made you do that?
- So I used to work at a
car magazine in Australia.
Originally, so what I did
was went to university,
didn't like that, studied-
- Just that quick?
Two lessons in, I'm done?
- It be like, it do be like that.
- I took a smoke break.
(all laughing)
- Yeah and just never came back.
I was just like, it's like, whatever.
Just something to do, I
don't know what I wanna do.
But I in the meantime,
while I was doing that,
I was studying animation.
- All right.
- Wow.
- The actual like physical
with pieces of paper.
And so, I was super hardcore
into this sort of stuff.
So I had my own thing
and I was doing like little
test things or whatever.
So then I started to learn 3D animation.
And this is back when, if you
heard of the program, Maya,
Maya, I was learning like
Maya 1.5 or something.
- Oh my god.
- Yeah, original,
it was running on IRIX boxes,
which is a Silicon Graphics IRIX,
which is like a proprietary UNIX system.
And one box would be like $12,000.
- Jesus.
- Yeah, to learn on.
So I learned this 3D software
because I wanted to do animation
because that's what I liked.
And did that, got jobs doing that,
which paid really well back then,
because no one knew how to do it.
- It was very specialized.
- Yeah.
You had to churn out content real quick.
And so I was young.
I was like 23 or four or something
and I just go there in the morning,
work hours and hours
and nothing else to do
so I'd always get the work done,
got paid really good.
Bought lots of anime, go home watch anime.
(all laughing)
Yeah, it was good.
So then, I got kind of burned out on that.
It wasn't what I'd imagined.
It was a lot of like-
- How long you're doing that for?
- Probably about five, six years.
- Oh, wow.
- I mean, it was good.
But it's very high, you know,
the crunches and things like that.
They just shovel content,
"Here, do all this stuff."
And you're like, "This sucks."
And you just sit there all day.
But at the same time,
I've got my headphones on
listening to Japanese lessons.
Because for some reason,
like I think if you're doing
creative work and language,
it doesn't mix in your head.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- I can sort of listen.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Like just again and again and again
so it just stuck.
- Right.
- While I'm doing that.
So then got burned out on that.
Came to Japan.
I wanted to do anime stuff and car stuff.
- Right.
- How did you come here?
Like what was the process like?
Did you get like a-
- No, I just did tourist.
- Oh, just tourist.
- Yeah, just as a tourist.
I wanted to see car stuff,
I wanted to see anime stuff.
So I went to Akihabara.
It was all in a notebook, all written out.
No Google Maps. None of this.
I didn't know what I was looking for.
- So what year was this?
- This was like 2005.
- Oh, fuck.
- Oh my goodness.
- I was blind.
- Yeah.
- I had two friends had been to Japan.
One who'd done car stuff.
One who'd done, he'd sort
of gone back to Akihabara.
So he's like drawing me
hand-drawn maps of like,
"Okay, so this is the LAOX building,
and if you turn this
way, there's the bridge
and you walk down that way,
'cause that's where all the stuff is."
Like okay.
'Cause I didn't have
any friends who wanted
to do car stuff and
anime stuff so by myself.
So, you've done the same thing, I'm sure.
You burn yourself out.
You get up in the morning
and go do stuff all day.
You don't eat, you don't drink.
You just do more of this sort of stuff.
You go to the hotel fall asleep, wake up,
let's do it again!
So I go out again and went up
to Ebisu Circuit by myself.
- And you went all the way
to Fukushima by yourself?
- Drove there, or?
- No, I took the train,
I was blind, a friend of mine
who worked at a magazine,
actually was a friend of a friend,
he worked at a magazine and I just said,
he sorta knew who I was.
So I messaged him like,
well, I emailed him.
And said, "Hey, can you tell me
how to get to Ebisu Circuit?"
He said, "Just go to Nihonmatsu Station
and just get in a taxi and
just say Ebisu Circuit."
(all laughing)
He said "Oh, are you going there?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
"Oh, can you write an article
about the event for the magazine?"
"Yeah."
So I've got my mum's little Panasonic,
like digital camera, 32
megabyte memory card,
Not gigabyte, megabyte.
- Megabyte.
- Right?
So I go up there, I see the
event, just blows my mind,
all this cool stuff, it
was a big competition,
which I now do the commentary for,
which is kind of cool.
- Yeah.
- Full circle.
- Go back, I write this
article and he's like,
"Oh, that was really good."
And then a few weeks, you
know about a month later,
he was like, "Do you want a job?"
"Yes, I'm sick of doing 3D, I hate it."
So, I started working at the magazine
and every chance I could, I come to Japan.
And this is how we did it.
This is how, these people have to remember
this sort of stuff.
You somehow make money when you come here.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- If you can.
Like people do that by
like making YouTube videos
and stuff like that.
So what I did was I would come here,
I'd go do car stuff.
I'd take photos of it, write articles,
go back and I'd get paid
for going on holiday.
Which is so fun.
- It's a double win.
- Yeah, it's like this is perfect.
- I have gamed the system.
(laughing)
- So I thought okay,
I got this figured out
and it got to the point
where literally everyone
I knew it was like,
"Lexi, just shut the fuck
up and go live there."
(all laughing)
That's all you talk about.
My car friends, everyone's like "Alexi,
Japan this, well in Japan,
well in Japan they do this,
in Japan they do that, so just go."
I said, "Okay, fine, I will."
So working holiday visa, right?
- Right.
- 18 months, okay.
I'm gonna quit everything,
sell everything.
I'm gonna live there
for a year and a half.
If it works out, if
I've had a good holiday,
I can just shut up about it
and get it out of my system.
If not, we'll see what happens.
So came here and just did the same thing,
just went around shooting
articles, writing things,
selling them to magazines,
selling them all around
the world in English.
And it just sort of built up from there.
So like taking photos.
Oh, look at these cool random photos
I've taken of this cool stuff.
I'll make a WordPress blog,
which is what everybody did back then,
this was like 2008.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, WordPress blog.
So that became a popular thing.
Then, oh, this is really cool,
I've got this little Sony vloggy camera.
It only shoots-
- I think I have the
exact same camera, yeah.
- So like oh, let's just shoot this car
doing something cool, 'cause it looks,
it's moving, it's making noise.
Here we go.
- Cars do that.
- That's what makes 'em cool.
- Was it the old Sony Handycams?
- It was a tiny little one.
- Oh, okay, okay.
So shoot all that.
And then that goes on YouTube.
Well, that becomes more popular.
You know, magazines aren't popular.
They don't make any money anymore.
They don't want to pay $800,000
for a big article these days anymore.
Okay.
YouTube pays money, let's do YouTube.
And it's just sort of
snowballed from there.
- So how did you transition
from doing all the online stuff
into then actually
living here permanently?
'Cause I assume you had to
figure out a way, right?
- Yeah well, and this is one
of the biggest questions,
everyone wants to know like,
"How do you live in Japan?"
- 'Cause we get it all the time as well.
- I'm sure, yeah.
It's a difficult thing because
there's so many people,
I'm sure you've had this same experience.
Like people who are living here,
it's like, "How are you living here?"
Like you don't, you have to do something.
- It's like what do you do?
- I have some people where I'm like, how?
- It's like what visa do you have?
How have you coined, how
have you gamed the system
in your own way, right?
- And it's sort of like,
you're not supposed to ask that question.
Like what visa and how are you here?
'Cause I mean, look, some people just,
they're lucky like, "Oh
my, my father is Japanese,
I got a visa."
Or not lucky, you know what I mean?
Like almost like it's a bad thing.
- Yeah.
- Or for some reason they're here.
So the way I did it was...
So originally working holiday visa.
And then when that started to run out was,
I thought, okay, I need to do something.
And I had a friend who lived up in Sendai,
who was a French guy and he was
actually running a magazine,
a French magazine.
He was running the magazine
as the editor from Japan.
So he was just getting all
this content from Japan,
just editing it.
And so he was on a journalist visa.
- Oh, okay.
- So I thought he said,
"Oh, you should do the journalist visa.
It's very easy."
(all laughing)
Sorry, JC, that's a bad imitation of you.
So I thought, okay, maybe I can do this.
So I applied for everything.
Now, remember when the
earthquake happened,
oh, you weren't even here
when the earthquake happened.
The earthquake-
- 2011?
- Yeah.
The earthquake happened
and I'd already sort of renewed once
and it worked and I thought,
okay, I don't know if I can do this again.
It was kind of easy the first time,
because I managed to get like
a contract from a magazine
and I don't know if it would
work these days or not,
but I had proof
that I'd been doing that
job for a long time.
And the best thing
about being a journalist
is you don't need any sort of-
- Like qualification?
- Yeah, you don't.
All you need is like,
I've done this for a long time.
- I'm a keep doing.
- Yeah, I'm a keep doing it.
These guys are gonna pay me to do it.
Okay, so I sort of convinced
a magazine to give me a contract.
Like, look, you want this content?
Give me a contract.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Right, okay.
- So I got that, I showed it to them.
Then again, that whole
earthquake thing happened.
And this was like
literally at the same time
I was meant to renew.
I thought, "Oh no, what
if they cancel me or?"
- Right.
- So, I mean, look,
everyone, I don't know about you guys-
- 'Cause then it's like
panic state, right?
- Dude, it's all-
- Yeah, what was that like?
(Alexi sighs)
- Okay.
When I...
It wasn't bad for me because
all I did was just sort of sit
at home for like a month
and just do nothing.
I just thought I'm just gonna
stay the hell out of it.
- Yeah.
- Until I need to do something.
Actually, I did go and help
a friend who was at Ebisu
who had a lot of trouble with
stuff falling down the hill,
like collapsing, anyway.
- Right, right, right.
- So I thought, okay,
I don't want to leave.
If I leave now, probably
not gonna come back.
'Cause a lot of, even hear of flyjin,
you heard that term?
- No.
- So foreigners who left Japan
when the earthquake happened
and was like, I'm out.
(all laughing)
- Flyjin!
- Was that a real thing?
A lot of foreigners left?
- Yeah, well, okay, it was
kind of derogatory thing.
It's like, "Yeah, you left."
It's like, I honestly don't
blame people who did that
'cause it was-
- Was it that bad?
- Understandable, have a nice day.
- I see footage of it,
but it's so hard to like
actually get a sense of it
because even the small earthquakes here
kind of like throw me off sometimes.
So I can only imagine what an earthquake
of that magnitude would do.
- I don't know, I don't think
people can quote me on this,
but wasn't it one of the
most like, financially,
it was one of the most like
devastating earthquakes,
slash tsunamis of all time or something?
- Well, probably the deadliest,
not the deadliest but-
- The one that did the most damage.
- Yeah, I think like it caused
the most damage financially.
- It did cause a lot of problems.
- Really fucked up the Japanese economy.
- Depending on how severe I hear it was
is depending on who I ask and
where they were at the time.
Because some people said like,
I've been told this like,
"It wasn't that bad, things
just started falling."
- No, it was bad. (laughing)
- But that's what I'm saying, right?
Depends on who you ask and
where they were at the time.
- Right.
- Because obviously if
someone experienced it
and it wasn't bad for them,
they probably think like eh.
- I mean, it was on like,
every country it was on news.
- Like it was fucking worldwide news.
- No, I know, I'm not saying it's not.
what I'm asking is like,
how was it for like you,
because everyone I've seemed to ask so far
has such a different explanation
of how it was for them.
- Personally, I mean,
when it actually happened,
I was just doing some washing at the time
'cause it was like in the afternoon.
And I thought, oh, I'm gotta take it down
to the laundromat and get the dryer going.
And some thing I was gonna hang up as well
and the windows started rattling.
I'm like, oh, it's windy.
Good, I can get my-
(all laughing)
- So I can wash this.
- I can hang my sheets
up, get them to dry.
And then all of a sudden
everything started,
I was on the second floor of a house
that I used to live in Saitama.
And it started to move, I'm
like oh earthquake, okay.
What do I do?
Okay, stand in the, so I
stood in the doorframe.
- Right.
- That's what you're supposed
to do I guess.
- I think that's what
you're supposed to do.
- And it started to, it's just doing this.
And I'm like okay, this is bad, wait,
I'm supposed to be a media guy.
Where's my camera?
So I grabbed my vloggy again
and I caught the last like
20 seconds of it on video.
And I aimed out the window.
All the power lines are
doing this and it's rattling.
And it's just crazy.
And I remember it like that too
and then it just kind of stopped
and there was a guy doing a delivery,
like (speaking in foreign
language) guy of the road
and he just kept doing the (indistinct).
(Garnt laughs)
- [Joey] Yeah, like nothing happened.
- Is anything gonna happen?
And I'm looking at,
there's no smoke rising.
It's okay, it should be okay.
And so I put my stuff in my laundry thing,
went down to the laundromat,
and I'm in there, just sitting
there waiting for it to dry,
I was like, okay, I'll go
shopping maybe in a minute.
And these kids walk
past the window outside
wearing those hats,
you know the foam?
Yeah, it's like this kind of-
- It's like a triangular-
- It's like a bandana
looking thing that they wear
and it's supposed to be fireproof?
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And like elementary school kids wear it,
to like kind of protect themselves-
- It's like a Red Riding Hood hood,
but it's like thick
foam made of reflective,
like an old fireman's hat sort of thing?
- My God yeah, in the UK,
they're like fucking get on with it.
(Joey laughs)
- Well, I mean, there's
nothing that happens in the UK
that's big enough to be
worried about, right?
- They will walk past
the window and I'm like,
What the hell are these?
Oh, they're wearing those things, okay.
And then in the laundromat,
sometimes there's a TV.
And I look up and there's
that the big black wall
of death just eating towns.
I'm like...
(Garnt laughs)
Oh, oh shit, I better go get some,
I better go and buy
some food or something.
So I went to the supermarket
and just bought a bunch of food
and I thought okay, and a
slab of beer and I thought...
(all laughing)
- Might be a long night.
- Well I thought if I'm
gonna be stuck at home.
And yeah, so it was okay for me.
The worst thing for doing car
content was there was no fuel.
They just cut, all the fuel got cut off.
So I was like, okay.
And what I actually did that month was
I had enough of a internet
presence then to say,
'cause I had a regular column
in a Japanese magazine actually.
And I said, "Hey, everyone,
send me a picture of
your foreign drift car."
And I got people to
make my content for me.
- You're a pro YouTuber.
(all laughing)
God damn.
- But up in Tohoku like up
where, especially where Ebisu is,
I had to go up there
to help a friend just-
- So you weren't in Sendai
when it actually happened?
- No, no, no, I wasn't up there.
- 'Cause my grandma lives in Sendai.
So she like-
- Yeah, 'cause what I've
heard is that from people
who were in Sendai near the epicenter,
it was awful,
but then I've heard a lot of
people in Tokyo who were like,
"Yeah, things were shaking."
- Yeah, I mean, for my grandma,
it was kind of like half-half,
because like she lives on quite
a big like apartment place.
I think she was on like the
13th or 14th floor or something.
And like obviously the higher up
on a building you are, right,
the more it's gonna shake.
So the shaking was bad but
it didn't break anything.
Like she didn't get injured or whatever,
but then she did tell me that
it was really scary that after
the rattling kind of stopped
and she picked herself back
up and looked out the window,
she could actually see tsunami
coming over the horizon.
- Oh my God.
- And then she was like, "Oh, Shit."
And so she turned the TV on
and then that really famous footage
of the black wall was just-
- Wait, what is the black wall?
- I just made that up.
The tsunami was just like a big churning,
dark mess of debris.
- It wasn't like this one big wave
that most people think it is.
It was kind of just this rush of water
that just swept over everything.
- Because it was just taking
all the debris with it, right?
So, it was just like,
it just turned a black
wall of like destruction
because it was hardly water anymore.
'Cause it was just like all the gunk
that it'd taken up with it.
- And just all the houses that were along
the coast were just getting crushed
as this thing came over
and yeah, it was horrible.
- Meanwhile, international
people like were like,
"But my anime."
- I remember, like Pokemon
got delayed or something?
- Madoka got delayed.
- And people were like,
"I can't believe this
is stopping the anime."
It's like, oh my God.
- It's like fuck you. (laughing)
- And trains were canceled for a while.
And they had rolling blackouts.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Luckily 'cause I was,
the grid that I was on at
my house was the same grid
as a big hospital and a
Japanese military base
so we never got a cut.
But here's the thing.
So what I was saying before
was I had to renew my visa.
And at that point you
had to get a reentry visa
to come back into the country.
Which means you have to
go to the visa center,
get like a $20 stamp in your
thing, in your passport,
so if you leave the country,
you can come back and everyone's leaving,
'cause it's like, well there's
radiation landing on Tokyo.
I mean, understandably.
So, and I was just, I thought okay, fine.
But I was like trying to renew
my thing at the same time.
So I went to the visa center
at like three in the afternoon,
which was a bad idea.
I drove there, out in Saitama.
And the queue was about
300 meters long of people.
I thought-
- What is this, Anime Expo?
(all laughing)
- I thought okay, here's
what I have to do.
Okay, I have to come
back tomorrow morning,
before the first train.
So my car, because my
car ran on premium fuel,
this is a drift car.
No fuel.
- Right.
(Garnt laughs)
- I like how you had to
mention premium fuel.
- Just reminding you, I'm a drift channel.
- It was a drift car.
- So I begged my friend, like,
please lend me your little Kei car,
your little small compact car
so I can drive there
before the first train
so I can get in line.
Get there, there's already about
maybe 50 meters of people lined up.
- Oh my God.
- I didn't get in the front door until,
I lined up like maybe 4:30 in the morning.
Didn't get in the front door
until two in the afternoon.
And then as soon as I
got in the front door,
everyone's going to the left,
I go to the right to renew.
And I walk up, there's
no one at the counter,
'cause they're all busy over here.
I'm like...
And so someone walks past is like,
"What do you want?"
"Oh, I want to renew."
And they're like, "Oh, okay."
They just take it.
And they sort of just
flicked through and like,
"You got your tax thing in there?"
I was like, "Oh, I forgot that."
It's like, "Eh, don't worry about it."
(all laughing)
- They just couldn't be bothered.
- They couldn't be
bothered, I got the renewal.
It was great.
And then just as I went back, I was like,
"Oh, that's over.
Thank God for that, I can go home."
Went to the car park to get my car,
it was a coin parking
with the little gates.
So I get in the car, go to
drive out and go to the gate,
put my money in the machine.
All I had was $100 like a
10,000 yen, like $100 bill.
You can put them in the machines here,
put it in the machine, the gates open
and it's like where's my change?
Four o'clock scheduled blackout.
- Oh no!
- Oh my God.
- So the machine ate
my hundred dollar bill.
I'm like, oh.
(all laughing)
Yeah, I look around and all
the lights are blanked out
and people are coming out of the bank
because it's just got blacked out.
I'm like oh no.
So anyway, I called up
and this being Japan,
there was a very lovely girl.
And she's like, answering
the phone and like,
"I'm sorry, the machine
ate my hundred dollars."
She's like, "Oh, don't worry.
(speaking in foreign language)
We'll make sure it's okay
and we'll send you the money.
We'll get you the
information of your bank."
Sure enough like a week
later, they did it.
- I mean, Japan's the one country
where you probably wouldn't mind
a machine eating your money.
- Yeah.
- You know you were getting that back.
- You can get it back, yeah, exactly.
- So, that was a thing.
So since then, but now
I'm married with kids
and I'm an adult now.
- [Connor] Gosh, terrifying.
- A proper adult.
- What's that like?
(chuckles)
- I gotta ask though,
because you came to Japan
obviously much earlier than us.
'Cause for us coming to Japan,
there's plenty of resources
for us to learn about
what Japan life is like.
We have like a lot of, way more vloggers
and more YouTube videos
and more resources that we can look at.
But what was it like for you?
Was it almost like coming in blind?
Like what was it like
coming to Japan back then,
compared to how it is now?
- The first time I came, oh, I'm sorry.
The time I moved here,
I already been here
about six or seven times,
- [Connor] God damn.
- Mostly doing work or
like what I said before
like I go on holiday and
so I had a lot of friends.
Make friends with people
who speak English and stuff.
You know, I'd have floors to sleep on
and contacts and things like that,
which with Japanese people,
they're very friendly.
You can impose on the
Japanese person terribly
for like two or three days
and they don't mind.
It's like, yeah,
you're only gonna be a
couple of days, that's fine.
So I had a pretty good idea
of what I was getting into at that point.
And I knew I'd have,
like I sort of set myself up with people.
Okay, I want to buy a car.
I want to somewhere to stay.
I need all this sort of stuff.
And I kind of worked out how to do it.
So it wasn't really that bad.
And I knew like, you know,
I bought a kick-ass laptop,
we've got internet.
When I first arrived and I was
staying at my friend's house,
they had internet then,
I'm like, "Oh what's the,
is there like a download limit?"
(all laughing)
I don't want to get
throttled and they're like,
"What's a download limit?"
(Garnt laughs)
I love this country.
- Every Australian coming to Japan.
- Does Australia still
have download limits?
- Oh, not now.
Well, probably-
- America does?
- No, it does, yeah.
- America does too and
I couldn't believe it.
I was like, what do you mean
you only get three gigabytes a month?
You can't do shit with that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's ridiculous.
- I use up like 20
gigabytes a day minimum.
- Yeah, for like YouTube
and Netflix nowadays.
How'd you do that?
- It's criminal man. It's criminal.
I wonder like, how is,
because I feel like when I've asked
Japanese people who have been,
who are like 30, 40 plus,
how Japan was back then,
they're like, "Oh, not much has changed."
But I think because
they've been living here,
they don't see it that way.
I wonder, like, as someone
who came here in 2005,
how is Japan like different
then from now like majorly?
Is there anything that's changed?
- The biggest thing, I mean,
there's been a quite a few changes
in the past year, honestly.
- True, true.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Pretty obvious you guys, but...
As from a foreigner's point of view,
accessibility to everything
is just wide open now.
You want to know how to
get to random little place?
Google. That's it.
And there's pictures
of what it looks like.
And it's just so easy.
Like no matter where you want to go,
it's much easier now.
Whereas back then, like for
example, going to Akihabara,
you'd find some random guy's blog
that he was like obsessed a bit.
'Cause the problem was like, back then,
people would flavor their
content with their own tastes.
- Buds.
- Yeah, buds exactly.
This guy was obsessed
with finding LaserDiscs
for certain things.
And LaserDiscs and porn.
(all laughing)
- You just forgot that thing.
- It's the only two reasons
you should go to Akihabara,
all right, LaserDiscs and porn.
- I mean, one of them's been phased out,
the other one hasn't been.
- The other one has
exploded in popularity.
(all laughing)
- So, it would tell you all
these places to go and here,
like where all the anime studios are,
like here's Gainax, here's whatever.
And it's like, if you want to go-
- Oh, they had a map of where they were.
- There wasn't a map,
it was just like this.
like it was like literally,
directions from the closest station.
Like walk to this corner and turn left.
- That's creepy.
- Yeah, it was weird.
But I mean it's-
- Just how it is.
- Yeah.
- You just find things like,
I've still got the first
notebook of my first trip.
There's a lot of like printed out maps
and handwritten notes
and things like that.
It's like-
- How do you navigate a
handwritten map of Akihabara?
Like looking through Google
Maps is already confusing.
- You just walk down the street and-
- Just hope for the best. (laughing)
- That's okay, go ahead.
- I mean but it's so,
no matter where you're turn,
it's like there's something.
- Yeah.
- And even if you want to look,
I've sort found about Japan is,
you focus on one thing
and then see what you find along the way.
'Cause you'd always
find these random like,
I mean all the best stuff is like,
oh, what's this random floor?
Oh, it's like some Doujinshi shop.
And go in like oh wow, there's
all this cool stuff here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- True, true.
- So you didn't really need it back then.
- Was there many foreigners back then?
Like in Japan?
'Cause there isn't that many now,
but I imagine it was even less back then.
- So for Akihabara, the biggest difference
between then and now is
there's less video games and
more of the claw machines.
- Ah, okay.
- The billboards are more blatantly,
how do I put it?
(all laughing)
- Just say it, say what it is.
- Well, a lot of titties and assholes.
- A lot of lewd stuff.
- Yeah, a lot of lewds.
- A lot more waifus now days.
- The concept of lewd is definitely,
like the boundary has gotten further.
- It's more like bam.
Although, on the other hand though,
the Eroge shops are not like
right out in front anymore.
- They're all on underground now.
- Yeah, back then,
like on the front of the Eroge shop,
it had like the big wall
with like each of the
games and a little ticket.
So you just, on the street, you're like,
I want, ah, I want this,
yeah, something, sister something.
(all laughing)
You go inside and buy it.
Whereas now it's more sort of all shut up.
It's more like tourist friendly.
Like they still have the maids and stuff.
Also yeah, the maid stuff.
That was none of that back then.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Oh was it not?
Like originally.
I mean, they were, but
now it's like every corner
it's like the new maid one.
Like there was the big ones,
but there's not all like
the little niche ones-
- Like the Ninja one.
- The ninja one,
the Tsundere one, the imoto one.
- I think I watched a documentary
yesterday of Akihabara.
And that was like 2005.
It was a horribly edited documentary.
It was like a horror show.
- I mean, that's what
every anime documentary
was like back then.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I didn't know what it
was supposed to be though.
Like it was, I couldn't figure it out.
But there was like maid cafe.
They were showing some maid cafes around,
but it looked like very early on.
Like, so I think like around-
- Like super sketch.
- I think that was around
the time it happened
because they were following
the author of Higurashi.
- Oh, okay.
- And his family.
It was really weird because
in this documentary,
for some reason, I know
this is going on a tangent.
It just made me laugh my ass off there
because it's super serious documentary
and the guy with Higurashi,
he had his whole family
helping him make it.
And then his dad was
in charge of research.
And his dad dead ass to the camera goes,
"Yes, I had to study how
much gas it would take
to blow up a classroom
for one of his novels."
And I was like what?
He said that?
Like, he said that like it was nothing.
Like, "How much gas to blow,"
how did you find that out?
Like what resources is there out there?
- It's the difference
between a large explosion
and a small fire.
- I'm like, but did you really have
to find out how much gas there was?
Could you not have made up
some arbitrary amount of gas?
- Yeah, who's gonna read
Higarashi and like fact check?
It's like, oh, I don't believe
that's the right amount of
gas to blow this classroom up.
- Yeah, I mean, come on like
a modern day America hadn't happened yet.
Come on, I'm joking.
(laughing)
- You want to be factually correct
in like how to fucking kill bodies, right?
And how to-
- Sorry for the tangent
but that was just about
a documentary in 2005.
- It was slightly different then.
Even more of the old
electronic stuff was still...
There still is now, but
I thought that was cool.
- That was the main stuff though?
- Yeah, like you turned
down some random alley
and it's all like Blade
Runner electronics and stuff,
like oh wow, this is really cool.
- Because my dad,
like when he first came to Japan,
it was like the mid 90s,
like kind of early to mid
90s, like before I was born.
And back then Akihabara
was called Electric City.
And nowadays there's barely any
of that shit anymore, right?
Like the electronics shops and everything
are like all behind like in alleyways or-
- Well yeah, there's
like the big anime shops
that if you actually go in the first level
in the back and you find all-
- That's where all the
electronic stuff is, right?
- Because like you go out of the train
and you see like the
Electric Town exit or-
- Yeah, the Electric Town exit.
- I remember first coming,
I was like why is it
called Electric Town exit?
Well, what does this got to
do with electricity at all?
(Joey laughs)
- Eventually, that's eventually
gonna be just be like the anime town exit.
(Garnt laughs)
I guarantee you.
- Going back to drifting,
I'm curious because
obviously normal YouTubers,
they have this kind of, I buy the camera,
I buy the shit, that's it.
I probably don't have to
spend much more money,
unless you're Mr. Beast, of course.
But I mean, is it hard
running a YouTube channel
where it requires you to
buy a bunch of fucking cars
and tires all the time?
How much a year do you
spend on tires alone?
- Oh.
It can depend on the
year, but I mean, one,
depending on the car,
like one tire can go between say
$40 or 40 to $120 per tire
depending on how good it is.
So let's say like 70 or $80 a tire.
So that's two.
And a regular track day,
you're probably gonna go
through four, if not more,
depending on how crazy it is.
- I see you upload sometimes weekly,
but it was like,
it was kind of sporadically
over a month, right?
And is that every single
time you're making a video
you're probably doing that?
- No.
Well, okay, these days I think I could
for various reasons, because the market
for people to watch those sorts of videos
is much bigger now.
- Has gone up.
- Oh, it's huge.
Like everyone watches YouTube now.
It's a thing.
That's the only place you can
get that sort of content too.
You can't really get it on TV,
'cause it's not a TV
or anything like that.
So right now is a really good,
there's a good lane for
automotive content right now.
But the most cost-effective content
is going to a meeting or
some sort of cool events-
- Like a festival.
- Where you don't have to spend money.
(all laughing)
- You just drive there, walk around going
"Hey guys, look at this cool stuff."
And the best thing about that is like,
if I know what I'm talking about-
- People will just watch.
- I'm providing value-
- That's kind of like your itasha video.
- Yes, and again,
that's another thing
that made me confident-
- Do you wanna explain
what that whole thing is?
- Oh, okay.
- What's itasha?
- Okay, so a lot of your audience
will know what these are,
so itasha is the anime waifu cars,
that are like wrapped
with like some character
or some theme or whatever.
- The ones that always get
upvoted on your Reddits
or pop up in your feed
every once in a while.
- Yeah, you see them like-
- It's like wow, I've never
seen any of these before.
You come to Japan and this
is entire festivals for it.
- Oh, yeah.
So what itasha means is,
so in Japan, when they refer
to a car like an American car,
you can say it's an amisha.
Like American car.
Itasha is usually Italian
car like Ferrari or whatever.
But they change the
character for like Ita,
like the Katakana to the Kanji for pain.
- Like, Itai.
- So itasha literally means pain car.
- Because as I explained the video,
when you look at it,
a normal person looks at
it and goes (cringes).
(all laughing)
- So basically, it's literally
more like cringe car.
- It's a cringe car.
- Yeah, cringe car is the most
accurately way of putting it.
But the people who drive
those sorts of things,
they just don't care,
they're like super hard core.
This is my waifu, and I love her and-
- There's not much bigger
of a flex than like,
how to represent your waifu,
slap it all over your car and
drive around in it, right?
- That's like the next
stage from just wearing
a T-shirt with your (instinct), right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
It's the step up, it is the
T-shirt then it's like the,
what do you call it?
The armor, like the badges
where they have all the full.
- Oh the (indistinct) stuff, yeah.
And then it's a plushy,
and then it's a figurine
and then it's a car.
- A car.
- And a lot of the cars too,
they put the (indistinct)
in there and stuff like that
on the dashboard.
- Yeah.
- So some of the most
popular content I've done
on Twitch and also on
YouTube was this itasha show
that they run every year in Tokyo,
down in Odaiba.
They didn't run it this
year, unfortunately.
- Obviously.
- Everything's canceled this year.
- Everything's canceled, unfortunately.
- No surprise.
- So when I made that video,
this was before I knew
there was such a big
crossover in audience-
- Between the anime and cars.
It's sort of like the Japan
anime, cars, there's a big,
there's actually a big
crossover in the middle there.
So, and even people who are like
maybe not necessarily into cars,
like people who will watch
"Initial D", they'll enjoy it,
'cause of the cool story
and it's action, whatever.
So there's all this sorta stuff too.
So I went to the show and I thought,
okay, how am I gonna cover this show?
I don't want to be like full on weeb,
"Hey guys, look at this, look at this."
- Look at this big titty anime girl.
- 34th edition anime girl
from the one manga panel
that you all know.
We all know it.
- Like I didn't want to come across too,
I didn't want to alienate my car audience.
But I still wanted to-
- You can say it.
You didn't want to come off as cringe.
- As cringe.
I want to hide my power levels.
(all laughing)
- Level one weeb.
- So I walked around
the show talking about,
I know about the car and
this is the character,
I'd explain like,
okay, this is like this show,
it's about this sort of thing or whatever.
Or this is my Madoka, the show is Madoka.
It's a bunch of magical girls
and they all die horribly
and it's really good.
- Well, so I've heard.
I don't know, I haven't watched it myself,
I've just heard things.
- And I'm making jokes too like,
I wonder what these
guy's girlfriends think
if they go pick them up
from the train station in these cars.
Oh wait, who am I kidding? (laughs)
- Meanwhile, inside, you're
like, God I wish that was me.
(all laughing)
- You're 100% right.
And some people actually
took big offense to like,
"Oh man, show some more respect
toward these things, man."
It's like you should be able
to understand, I'm actually-
- It's clearly an inside joke, right?
- Yeah, so anyway.
So that got really popular,
and all of a sudden I realized,
oh, I've got this audience.
And then, next time that show ran,
I did a live stream on Twitch.
And it's probably one of the best,
maybe not the biggest
numbers I've ever done,
but probably the most
engagement I've ever done.
I blew out my data for that day,
I'm like, "No, we gotta
keep going, it's great."
I covered this whole show.
It was really good.
I actually talked to TV.
There was a TV crew there
and they talked to me
and I didn't actually make it on the show.
I think because they asked like,
"So, what do people overseas
think of these cars?"
And Japanese TV wants the nice response.
"Oh yes, they're very wonderful."
I basically sort of said like,
'cause I was on the live stream
and I didn't want my audience
to think I was trying
to be fake or something.
- Right.
- So I was like "Yeah,
a lot of them say like,
there's a lot of like really
young girls on the cars
and they think that's kind of weird."
(all laughing)
I mean, what do you want me
to say, there's like you know?
- Cameraman swinging.
- All their TV is hyper positive here.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- Don't say bad things.
- I didn't really care.
- Especially Japanese TV.
- I was memeing for the Twitch-
- It was a pug moment, it's all right.
- Dude, it's a different beast
when there's a Twitch chat on you,
because it turns you into like
the memer side of yourself.
'Cause you don't Twitch chat-
- It turns you into the worst person.
- It's the same thing with
the Crunchyroll Anime Awards.
I didn't want to be cringe.
So I was like fuck,
Twitch chat's watching me.
What would Twitch chat respond to?
Just troll, just say dumb
shit which they will love.
So they can go like, "Pug no way."
(all laughing)
- Yeah, because I remember I,
'cause that itasha video of yours
I think was from like 2017 or something.
- Yeah, it was a long time ago, yeah.
- Like two or three years, at least.
And I when I heard
that you were gonna come onto the show,
I was like, okay,
I've got to obviously do
some research on the guest.
And I found that itasha
video and I'm like,
"Why does this video look so familiar?"
And I remember I watched that video,
I think like maybe like two or
three days after it came out.
Because I don't know if you remember,
but like that video initially
was getting recommended everywhere.
- 'Cause I watched that
video as well back then.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
It was... (laughing)
- What he's trying to say is
he knew you before you were big.
(Garnt laughs)
- I knew you before you were big, yeah,
but it was cool as well because like
I obviously knew very quickly that like,
as you were kind of
explaining the different shows
and whatnot, I could
very clearly being like,
"Oh yeah, this guy knows this shit."
But he clearly doesn't
want like show it all.
It's like yeah, this
guy's definitely a weeb.
- Like I've been a closet weeb before,
I recognize my fellow brethren.
Do you know what I mean?
Coming from being an old school weeb,
what is your opinion of
like the modern anime scene
and modern anime culture?
- Oh, man.
Okay so, I think...
So this is the interesting
thing is when I moved here,
you'd think like oh, now
I have unlimited access
to all this stuff.
I can just do it now.
I actually didn't, I
actually ended up quitting.
You know what I quit on?
- What?
- The last thing I actually
sat down and watched
like I'm gonna sit there and watch this
was the "K-On!" movie.
- Wow.
- That is such a fucking throwback for us.
- Oh my God.
- Holy shit.
- Why?
- I don't know, but I
watched that and I'm like-
- I would quit anime if I watched that.
- Okay, question, did you
like the "K-On!" movie?
- No, I didn't.
- Did you like K-On though?
- I liked K-On.
- Okay, okay.
- There's something nice
about the thought of someone
in a cinema watching
"K-On!" and then thinking,
I'm done with anime now.
(all laughing)
It's over for me.
- I don't know if it was,
maybe it was just like that's enough
or maybe it was 'cause
a combination of like,
well now I'm in Japan,
it's like all this stuff that you see-
- Doesn't feel as like unique and as-
- Well, it's there.
- It's not as romanticized anymore, right?
- I don't know if I read it somewhere
or someone's told me this
but when you come to Japan,
you realize that manga
artists are actually,
they're not creative,
they're just really good
at representing real life
in a very consumable way.
- Right.
- It's true.
- And that's not a bad thing.
Obviously that's great.
Like that's really good about reading
the sort of the daily life genre.
- Like "K-On!"
Like "Yotsuba", like all
those sorts of things where
it's all the stuff you've
see in those is real life
just sort of compressed into like a form
where you can consume it all really quick.
And I think that's a great thing.
That's makes it really enjoyable
to read or watch or whatever.
But I just sorta like, yeah, that'll do.
(all laughing)
And unfortunately that was
also at the peak of what is,
I guess was known as the moeblob, right?
- Yeah.
- And it just kind of ended up,
I don't know it just
sort of turned me off.
Like, yeah, I don't-
- Yeah, as much as I love the moeblob era
or like kind of halfway through it,
I was like, all right, can
we get something else now?
- I hated the moeblob era.
I remember like I,
so the reason I haven't
watched "Fullmetal Alchemist"
was because that was
during the moeblob era.
And that was when I thought
I needed to save shows
in case I lost my faith in anime.
'Cause there wasn't enough
shows coming out per season,
to like keep my interests.
- That wasn't moeblob, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then the Isekai era started.
I'm like okay, boys, I'm good.
- The what?
The Isekai era.
So now-
- Right now we're on the Isekai era.
- Okay, see.
Now, I hate that.
(all laughing)
- I like that you hate that.
- I'm sorry, everyone, I
just can't stand Isekai.
- It's boring, it's so boring.
- Yes, yes.
- I don't want to see a
bunch of normal teenagers
in like some fantasy,
you know, I get it.
It's it's cool but it's-
- No, it's not cool.
- It's not cool.
- As someone who likes the Isekai era,
I can definitely say like
most of it is fucking trash.
- It's not self-aware enough.
It's basically like an
RPG game, but it's real.
It's like all of you would get annihilated
the first time you faced an enemy.
(all laughing)
All the characters and stuff.
- That's true.
- What is the original,
there's one called
"Escaflowne", you know that one?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I guess that's like an
original sort of Isekai.
- That was an Isekai before the real,
the modern Isekai formula really started.
- But that was good I
think, 'cause it was like
you were dragged into this world
and it was all this crazy shit.
Whereas now it's more like,
yeah, this is us, yay, and
it's just like I don't know.
That just turned me off even more.
- Yeah, I'd say like
Garnt and I covered this
when we did the Isekai anime tier list,
but "Escaflowne" and "Now
and Then, Here and Now"
are probably the two
shows from like the 90s
that like really kind of
built the foundations.
- I'd say there's "Inuyasha" as well.
- "Inuyasha" as well.
And then ".hack" came along
and kind of put in the
whole video game aspect
into the Isekai thing.
And then, and now we're here
and it's just kind of (whistles).
- I feel like Isekai back then,
it was all about you get
transported to this world,
but it was always about
finding your way back home.
'Cause it was always a desolate,
kind of rough world to be in.
But now it's all about, man-
- I love this place.
- I wanna get hit by a truck
so I get transported to another world.
- There's so many fucking
shows where it's a teenage boy
who's a fucking incel and then he turns up
and eight girls wanna fuck him.
(all laughing)
And then it's never mentioned
that he came from
another world ever again,
unless it's kind of convenient
for why other people wanna fuck him.
And it's like I'm so
bored of this shit, man.
Can I get something else, please?
Needless to say it, I'm
kind of bored with Isekai.
- Yeah, the other one too,
I don't know if this is
kind of controversial or not
but the genre of where,
okay, how do I explain this?
Where you have, it's like a harem anime,
but the main character is not male.
They're a female,
they're female, but it's like
they're basically a male,
but for the convenience of
the story, they're female.
Like what's the dragon one?
- Dragon one?
- With-
- Are you talking about stuff
like "Ouran High School"?
- No, no, no.
The one with, what's that character,
Kanna and the other one?
- Oh "Kobayashi's Dragon Maid."
- Like the main character is a female,
but it's actually male,
if you think about it.
- It's like a position of a male, right?
- Right, no, no, she's female.
(laughing)
- I don't have the resources for this.
(Garnt laughs)
- She's a female or is she?
- Oh, am I missing something?
- No, no, no no.
- And there's other ones like that too,
where it's kind of like,
yeah, the main character is female,
but it's an analog of a male,
but it's female, so it's okay.
And it's just like, ah, it's
just even worse, I don't know.
- Yeah I get the genre
you're talking about.
I'm just trying to think of other ones
that kind of fit into that genre.
- I have no fucking clue.
- I can't remember the name of it,
but there's other ones too
where it's kind of like
that and it's like eh,
it's kind of on the edge.
- So, you didn't like "Dragon Maid"?
- No, I didn't like it.
- Really?
- It's just kind of too
on the edge of like...
It's not actually lewd guys. (chuckles)
(all laughing)
- Not gonna lie, if it was a
toss up between watching anime
and fucking tearing a
car to shreds on a track.
- Yeah, I would tear a car to shreds.
- That's probably gonna be my hobby.
Let's be realistic.
I think there are differences.
There's a $6 a month subscription
and like a $30,000 problem.
How much is it,
does it cost a drift on
a yearly basis, for you?
- Oh, man.
It can vary but-
- Rough estimate.
- If I had to throw out
a budget, like, okay,
you're gonna need this
much a year to drift,
car, fuel, insurance, registration,
maintenance, and the occasional like
you're gonna stuff it into a wall
and you're going to break a bunch of shit,
oh, at minimum,
at minimum maybe like $30,000,
If you want to drift maybe once a month
or once every couple of months
at like one track day.
- I mean, needless to say,
the kids don't get good
Christmas presents.
(all laughing)
- No.
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- Would you like an Noriyaro hoodie?
You just give them your merch.
- You're like daddy's got
you something special.
It's just a fucked up tire. Here you go.
- Noriyaro touched this.
- Just buy them one of
the tires and be like,
are you gonna use that?
If you can't use that, daddy
can use that, you know.
(all laughing)
- Some premium oil for you here children.
- Have you ever thought about
getting an itasha yourself?
- Yes.
- Oh, really?
- What would you get?
- I loved the zero hesitation there.
He's like of course.
- Okay, I turned 40 years old this year,
so I don't know how, I really don't know.
See there's two ways you can do this.
There's the one way we can
just be shameless and like,
this is my waifu, but
there's the other way,
'cause a lot of Western
people are very like timid
when it comes to the itasha.
Like it'd be like Dragon Ball
or something where it's not-
- Normy as hell.
- No, no, no, it's not.
Whereas here it's like
some studio leaf, you know-
- Like visual novel?
(all laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
And it's like, this is what I fap too.
Like that's it.
So I guess if I was gonna do it,
I'd have to go hard in and go like-
- Okay, who's your waifu?
- Who is it then?
- I just don't know.
I don't have any of these days.
I thought-
- Who was the OG waifu for you?
Like the one that you first was like, yes,
this is my waifu.
(Alexi groans)
- A long time ago, I really
liked Lum from "Urusei Yatsura."
- Holy shit, that's the OG waifu.
- You can't get more OG than Lum.
I'm pretty sure she was
like one of the first waifu
to ever exist.
- Like the eye shadow and
the bikini and everything.
- Yeah.
- I have no idea what this
character is or looks like.
- You've probably seen her.
She's the one with like the green hair
and like the tiger.
- The tiger bikini.
- Yeah, I've seen that.
- Like those horns.
- I just got this great image of you
like rocking up to your kid's school
in like an (indistinct) just
like picking up your kids,
like, "Come on, kids, get in."
(all laughing)
- It's like, "That's not
my dad, that's not my dad."
- Man, I got in trouble, 'cause like the,
I just drive a van now.
It's like a regular looking sort of van.
But the van-
- Free candy.
(all laughing)
- The van I had before was,
I'm probably gonna do
this with my current one,
'cause I've okay,
so drift people, their thing is stickers.
- Right.
- I guess it's sort of, I mean,
a lot of things do that too,
but like you meet someone,
here's my sticker, here's
your sticker, yeah?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I've got a huge collection of stickers.
I've done like sticker
sorting streams on Twitch.
I've done like three of them.
So it took like six hours,
I guess, to do them all.
So I put them on the rear door,
of the gate of the car or the back window,
you know, whatever.
I'm sorry.
And, I did that with my previous van,
which I sold a while ago.
And unfortunately one of them I stuck on,
I didn't read what it said.
It was written Japanese, it
was an Australian Drift Team
but they put like random shit on there.
And it said, what did it say?
It said (foreign language)
or something like that.
- Oh my god.
- Can you translate that for us, Joey?
- Elementary school kids are awesome.
- Yeah.
- What?!
Why did they have that?
- I don't know.
I don't know.
I guess it was like some,
they were trying to be edgy or something.
'Cause it was like one
of those sort of, okay.
So a lot of-
- This is the one country
where you shouldn't
have a sticker like that.
- Yeah, a lot of animes,
a lot of, again, this crossover thing,
there's a lot of these
like sort of anime style
slap stickers that they make.
They have like some random anime titties
and like some team name or whatever.
And they'd done this.
And I didn't check what it said
'cause again, they came to Ebisu Circuit,
like a lot of foreigners
come to Ebisu Circuit
and they stuck it on there
and I didn't read it.
And then my wife saw it.
(Joey laughs)
She's like, "What the fuck is this?"
And I'm like, "What?"
She goes, "This sticker here."
I'm like shit, I didn't
want to peel it off
because it was stuck on the paint,
'cause it probably would
have peeled the paint off.
So I got like a black marker.
(all laughing)
- I want to get it off immediately
but I don't wanna ruin the car.
- Well, yes.
Now I vet my stickers
before I put them on.
I probably should have done that.
- It goes through screening process.
- I have like, a fucking
irrational fear of stickers.
- Why?
- I have no idea.
The thought of stickers.
You know how like people used to
when you were in school,
people just put stickers on each other,
I used to be disgusted
if people did it to me.
- Why?
- I don't know.
Just fucking freaked me out.
People putting stickers on me,
I'm like, that's disgusting.
Get that off of me.
I hate stickers.
They are like the worst thing ever.
Magnets, I'm cool with, no problem.
Stickers, gross.
I don't know why.
- What is it like the stickiness of it?
- I think it's the stickiness, the sound.
I'm like that's disgusting,
get that away from me.
- The sound?
- Get that away from me.
- The sound the stickers
make I fucking despise.
- You don't put any stickers
on any of your products
or anything at all?
- I have one on my laptop,
it was a gift and I felt bad not to,
but a part of me, it
pained me so fucking much.
- Well, Connor fans,
next time you're at a con-
- Don't fucking bring me stickers.
- Give him stickers.
- I know what I'm getting
for your Christmas present now, Connor.
- I'm getting you a sticker book for your-
- I shouldn't have said that.
I should have kept my
irrational fears to myself.
- That's like going in
front of an audience
and being like this is my weakness.
- Well, I also have a weakness of money.
I can't stand people
putting money in my pockets.
So, if you wanna...
Sorry.
- It's called Patreon.
- I can't stand it.
- Connor, you're like the one guy,
who was like most into cars,
now, you can't be a drifter now,
because you don't like stickers.
- Do they put car, that would piss me off.
- Stickers is the main thing.
- If someone came up and put
a sticker on my car, I'm like,
"What have you done?"
You've ruined my car.
- People do that.
Okay, so my, at Ebisu Circuit,
I have a Skyline that I actually,
I leave it there,
like it's my car that I
drive when I go there.
And I've told people like,
"Hey, if you come to Ebisu,
just put a sticker on my car."
- Fuck, that would drive me up the wall.
Don't fucking touch my car.
(all laughing)
- That's just how you make friends.
That's how you bond.
- It is.
- The sticker does not consent.
- I'll stick your car if you stick my car.
- I'll bring a plastic sheet right now,
I'll drape it over my car.
Put the sticker on that.
The moment I leave, fucking rip that off.
(all laughing)
I didn't know that, wow. Go on.
- I have people like,
it's a tourist attraction.
They send me selfies
like, "Ooh, drift car."
'Cause it's sort of like,
I guess sort of semi-internet famous.
- I've never been so horrified in my life.
- Oh, you can't be a drift driver then
if you don't have stickers.
- Fine, after I did the drifting,
I was like telling the
boys outside, I was like,
"You know what, I actually
think I'd get into this.
It was pretty fun."
- But first you have to get over
your irrational fear of stickers.
- I'm willing to put that aside.
- You know the worst thing is,
so when you, when you buy tires
and you know drifters usually,
they fit their own tires,
then you save money.
Tires have a big sticker on them.
It's so like the brand,
you have to peel it off.
(imitates sticker peeling off)
- Fuck, I can do that.
I can get rid of them.
I hate people who put stickers on things.
It looks so tacky as well.
- Well, I agree with you.
- I fucking hate it.
- I agree.
But it's sort of like who you know.
- It's a badge, it's almost like a badge.
- It convenient.
- Joey's fucking laptop
disgusts me when I see it.
- Why?
- I'm saw it.
- This man has so many
fucking stickers on it.
It drives me insane.
- It's not even that many.
- Oh, Jesus Christ.
- [Alexi] That's pretty normal.
- It's like, someone's spreading
their ass cheeks in front of me.
I'm like, get outta here, man.
- It gives me all the memories, like,
I remember when I got
all of these stickers.
- That's it.
Yeah, you know, like on my van it's like-
- Just take a photo.
- Like I'll go to a
workshop and they're like,
"Oh, can we put one on",
it's like I've been here,
I know these people.
- I'm just the guy who's just never been,
I've never been given stickers
or anything like that.
- Do you have to memory,
like out of memory,
by fucking destroying my items?
- Okay, do you buy stickers?
- Sometimes, yeah.
- 'Cause I've never been a guy to be like,
I see a sticker, this is what I need.
This is my memorabilia.
- Because they're always the budget item.
It's always the pity item or whatever.
It's always the T-shirts or anything else,
I guess we have stickers.
- There's a sticker shop actually
in Harajuku called B-Side Label.
That I go to quite often where it's like,
it's these like, really
like some of those stickers
on there are from there.
And it's just, I don't know.
It's like really cool design.
It's like, but then again,
I was always like huge into
stickers when I was a kid,
I was that one kid who
had like books and books.
- I can tell.
Joey has this off-camera obsession
with what he calls peelies, right?
Like, so whenever-
- Don't expose my fetish
like that, please.
(laughing)
- So, every time we get
some new kind of furniture
or contraption, they have
like the plastic peelies.
- Oh, the peelies, right,
you understand it, right?
You have to go as slowly as possible.
- There's people who like it.
And then there's Joey.
I swear to God, he fucking
has a 10th of an orgasm,
every time he does a single peel.
He's just like, "Can
I, can I, can I do it?"
And then you just see,
he just does it slowly.
I'm just like, "Yo, Joey, do
you want me to leave you alone
for like five minutes, man?"
- Dude, I fucking love it.
You understand, all right?
- Especially when it's
like the clear stuff,
not that, it's like when
it's that dark blue one
that's like (imitates peeling).
- Yeah!
- New phones I like it
'cause you can whoosh.
- No, no, you can't go fast with it.
You got to go slow.
- Slow.
- You gotta tease it.
You got to tease it, you know?
It's gotta make that
like (imitates peeling).
- Look at the glossy surface underneath.
- Yeah, exactly.
See, Alexi gets me.
- I get it, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Is this some Australian
thing that we just don't get?
- There wasn't a lot to do
in Australia, all right.
- And also when you're a kid, right?
People would always like
when you went to the hospital
or the dentist, they'd always
give you a fucking sticker.
- Yeah, I loved that shit.
- When I was like six,
I was like, "Bold of you to assume
I want this fucking thing on me.
Don't you fucking dare give me a sticker.
- I think I have the exact same fear of,
like irrational fear,
but not with stickers,
but with like buttons and badges.
- I don't like those.
- I don't like badges.
- Wait, what do you mean?
- Like the pin badges, right?
- Yeah, the pin badges,
'cause I didn't get stickers.
I would get like those pin badges
and I'm like, don't you
fucking put that on me.
Don't you fucking touch me, miss.
- Yeah, I was never into the pin badges
because if you collect a lot of them,
they just make way too much fucking noise.
- I never understand people who
go to like anime conventions
and they buy the pin badges of like,
if you're gonna buy
any anime memorability,
why the pin badges?
Anything else, but pin badges?
- Dude, Japan fucking love pin badges.
I don't know what it is.
Like every single,
like you'll find like a
new anime series, right?
And you're like, "Okay,
I'm looking forward
to when they're released merch of this."
And then they're like, "All right,
we've released merch of it.
Have a pin badge."
It's like, "I don't want it man."
- It's like detergent of like,
it'll be like fucking Eva slash detergent,
cross fucking promotion.
And it'll have like, it's
got a sticker of Eva in it.
And it's like people
go fucking nuts for it.
I'm like what's wrong with you? What?
- I mean, I'm one of those
who was like hell yeah.
- It's like the holy
trinity of just useless
anime merchandise is stickers,
pin badges and clear files.
- Clear files are the fucking worst.
No one needs this many clear files.
- I mean, I have a clear
file full of clear files.
(laughs)
I can't say anything, but-
- I just kinda end up using
it because you know, they say,
it's says clear file, but
they're always got some stuff.
- You can't see it.
- It's the unclear file.
- It defeats the purpose of a clear file.
- It's got all the anime shit on it.
- It's just a file. (laughing)
- Anyway, we went on a
massive tangent there.
- Yeah.
- So you talked about your opinion
of like the modern anime scene.
What are some of your favorite anime?
Because I don't think we mentioned that.
- It's normie as hell, but I mean,
I always just enjoyed "Evangeleon."
Like back then, because it was-
- [Joey] Yeah, of course.
- I'd say it's less normie
now than it was back then.
- I guess so, but back
then, so in Australia,
I'd seen a lot of stuff,
but then it came out on TV on SBS,
which is like a public
channel in Australia.
- Where they like air a lot
of the international shows.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah.
There was a show, there
was a guy called Des Mangan
who presented like the
cult movies and stuff.
And sometimes it'd be anime.
And I was like, "Anime's
on tonight, yeah."
Yeah, back then, whatever
you could get, you took it.
Like it'd be professionally subtitled,
it would be really good.
And they would show "Evangelion",
they had like an anime block
where they showed some stuff for awhile.
And that was good because
that came out on TV
so everyone had a shared
experience of it at that time.
So, you know what I mean?
Like it, I think it's very important
that shared experience when it comes
to this sort of media, I think.
Like it's mostly about video games,
that sort of thing.
Like if you meet
someone's who played like,
Final Fantasy VII, it's like,
you immediately have a
huge thing in common.
- Like, what's your favorite part?
- Yeah, yeah.
- We've all done the same
thing at the same time.
And that was probably the first time
that like mainstream
anime was shown on TV.
So you sort of discovered other
people who were into it too,
because they'd watch it.
It was accessible.
So I guess that it had a bit
of an impact and it was very,
it wasn't the standard
monster of the week show.
There's a lot more to it
and I'm not trying to
sound like it's super deep
or anything 'cause it wasn't,
but it was just, really,
it solidified like-
- It was engaging, right?
- It was very engaging.
It wasn't afraid to make
something different,
like a show that's a bit different,
but at the same time he
used every trope combined,
like, yeah, whatever-
- That's the weird thing
about a lot of anime.
It is the most tropey unique
shows that for some reason,
get the most attention.
It's like, you look at it,
like someone will look at it and be like,
like Eva, for instance, right?
Someone will look at Eva and being like,
"Whoa, I've never seen
anything like this at all."
But at the same time,
it's the type of show where
another person will look at it
and be like, this has every
trope that I've ever seen.
- Dude, "One Punch Man."
- Yeah.
- Okay?
My cousin's kids a
couple of Christmases ago
when I went back and they've
started talking about,
"Oh yeah, we watched this
thing, "One Punch Man."
It's really cool."
And I blew their minds by going,
"This is actually based on
a little kid's TV show
called 'Wanpanman.'"
(all laughing)
And that character is based on like
the "Dragonball" character,
this one and this,
it was actually voiced by the same guy-
- You dropped the anime knowledge on them.
- I just, I explained-
- Man, Mr Worldwide over there.
- You fucking schooled them, man.
- So everything you like is actually based
on something else.
(all laughing)
- Your life is a lie, don't be happy
and I'll tell you why.
- That's exactly what I
was aiming to destroy them
'cause, yeah, it was just fun.
- Not gonna lie, doing that is fun.
- Destroying them with facts and history.
- See, that's what this is.
And so you actually like this,
you should actually like this.
But again, it's a gateway thing.
Hey, anything that gets people into it,
it's like, look, I
don't, who cares anymore?
Like, "Oh, you're a bunch of
normie fans, what do you know?"
It's like, no, you start
somewhere, you go this far.
It's like the same thing
you guys have done drifting.
If you don't want to go any further,
it's like, well, why would you?
Like if you don't understand
enough, that's fine.
You enjoyed it.
It was like you got your adrenaline hit,
and it was some weird stuff
you've never done before.
You have a new experience that
you've done, it's in Japan.
You've done drifting in Japan.
Like that was, I guess this
is the thing that I have
to offer to other people.
And I always try and not force it on them,
but if I can, at some opportunity,
like for example,
when Reckful and Sodapoppin came to Japan
for their legendary stream
on Twitch, their IRL stream,
I hunted them down and said,
"You have to come and go drifting."
'Cause Team Orange had
two of their drift cars
at a dive bar, which is only about-
- Very close to Central Tokyo.
- Yeah, less than an hour
from anywhere in Tokyo
to go drifting.
So, 'cause I know them, I hooked it up.
I said, "Yeah, come
here, we'll meet here."
We take them, sent them drifting.
They went out that night
and did Ram and Rem cosplay
play on the streets.
(all laughing)
So I guess they had a good day.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Other guys like, the
IRL stream of JakeNBake,
the Japanese IRL stream.
I got him a ride in a D1 Grand Prix car,
it was about maybe 1200 horsepower GTR,
live streaming it to like whatever it was,
like 20,000, 12,000, whatever people.
I love to, if I can just
present it to people as like,
'cause I honestly,
I think it is a really good
part of Japanese culture
that is not only fun and relatable but,
I mean any, like you said,
you know it because of "Fast and Furious",
people saying "Initial D"
and I think it's a cool thing
that I like people to
experience and I enjoy it.
- They're super welcoming as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They were really friendly
to us at the track.
- Now, if only every
community was like that.
(all laughing)
- Oh, go ahead.
- Go ahead.
- Okay no, 'cause I was going to say,
I mean, like you talked about
getting people to experience
this for the first time.
I'm sure we've done that
like introducing our friends
and everything into anime
where we can just like
recommend a show or something.
But I feel like it's
infinitely harder with drifting
because like, as we've talked about,
the barrier of entry is like so high.
And I feel like it's one of those hobbies
where no one just casually
drift, you know what I mean?
(all laughing)
You can't just be a casual drifter.
You like either in this all the way,
or like, it's something
you experienced once
and you know, I would
love to go drifting more.
It was a fucking hell of an experience,
but at the same time, it's like,
"Do I have the time and the
money to commit to this?"
And it's something-
- Just quit gacha.
He said he spent like 30K, we said?
- That's a minimum.
- That's probably
Garnt's monthly allowance
on gacha, come on.
Quit gacha.
- He was telling me on the
train here that he's like, "Man,
I would go drifting.
I just have to quit gacha."
(all laughing)
"But it's so hard."
- I think one thing
that I really appreciate
about your channel in particular,
and to anyone listening,
that whereas a lot of YouTubers here
who live in Japan who are foreign,
it feels like an outsider looking in
on a lot of the content.
And what was really refreshing
I think from your videos,
what I got was that it was
like you were in it with them
and that you knew all the
big players in the scene.
It was really cool seeing that aspect
'cause I thought, when I
first watched your video,
that it was gonna be like,
"Hey, I'm here, let's
find out what's going on.
I'm gonna see what's happening."
But you were like saying hi to
everyone, everyone knew you.
It was so cool.
- I roll deep.
- Yeah, it was really cool seeing that,
you get a YouTuber in Japan
who is really deep in the scene
to the point of where even the people
in the Japanese scene would know you.
It's really cool seeing that.
- That mostly came from the
fact that back in the day
when I was doing, journalist work-
- You've been around so long.
- Well, it's like, if I want
to get access to cool stuff,
I have to make friends.
- [Connor] Make friends.
- I have to get to known to people
and have to show them.
You know, I would, any
event I would show up.
This is the thing about
anything about Japan,
especially is show up.
Obviously right now you
can't really do that.
But if you want to be
in something, show up,
talk to people, get to know people.
I mean, I've been on tours of,
like a couple of anime
studios because I'm friends
with someone else who knows someone else.
And you just because you know someone
and "Oh, Alexi's into that stuff.
Why don't we go?
Do you want to come too?
We're doing something."
It's just knowing people and yeah.
Eventually it gets to a
tipping point where it's like
you show up and like,
"Oh yeah, there's Alexi."
That's why my friends told me,
like when I first got here,
it's like it's very difficult
for a Japanese person
to get to know and trust a foreigner
because they just assume
that you're not gonna be here
in a year or so.
And another person told me too like,
"Alexi, you have to keep
going to track days again,
like all the time.
Because if you don't,
people just gonna forget
about you, straight away."
So I do make an effort
to, even if I don't,
even if I'm not driving,
like I got today off,
I'll go to the track.
Maybe I'll make a, I'll
take my equipment with me,
maybe if there's something
cool, I'll make a video.
But otherwise I'll just hang
around and talk to people
and walk through the pits
and everyone "Morning, morning."
(speaking in foreign language)
And then eventually they'll come to you,
"Oh Alexi, (speaking in foreign language)"
and they'll have something
cool and someone will be like,
"Oh, are you driving today?"
Ah, no, I just turned up.
"Oh, you wanna take my car
out for a couple of laps?"
I'm like hell yeah.
I've got my helmet in the van.
I'll bring my helmet with me just in case.
- Take the shirt off like the whole team.
- I'm ready.
- Got my race suit on.
(all laughing)
Yeah, it's just show up and do it.
And it gets like that after a while.
I mean, I've been here 12 years, so,
and I've been coming here
for longer than that too.
- I think that kind of applies
with any social situation.
- [Alexi] Absolutely.
- It's like, it's just
about commitment, right?
Like you just got to,
if you want to be known in that circle
or you want to be part of that circle,
whatever that circle might be
or whatever that niche might be,
if you don't make an effort
to want to actually show,
your commitment to it or
want to be like part of it,
then you're not gonna get in.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- I was gonna say like it's the same thing
with like the anime industry as well.
Like once you know a couple of people,
it's such a small industry
that your face just gets known everywhere
as long as you're staying committed to it.
Like, that's really the only reason why
like any of us have like-
- That's just like our friend Nabi
in like a nutshell, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Like he just seems to know everyone.
And when I ask him,
it's just, he just says,
"Oh, you know, I just know
a guy, who knows a guy who,
I've just been around enough."
- I just go around and
just make myself known.
That's so, but the thing is
that's like so much easier said than done.
Because it is a lot of
commitment and it does take time
and it's not guaranteed either
that you're gonna get results.
- No, it's just you got to build up
recognition and everything.
'Cause it was interesting
you mentioned a point that
people in Japan just
assume people are gonna
to be living here, like unpermanently.
'Cause having lived abroad
in a few different countries,
there's like you make some
expat friends sometimes, right?
Who you can be like the
closest friends with them
for like a few years,
but then eventually
they're gonna move back.
And it's really hard building up
a friendship from zero again,
when you knowsometimes that
people aren't gonna to be here
in like two or three years.
- Yeah, I've definitely noticed that,
that I even I made some
friends who had just moved here
and I'm like, "Oh cool,
I'm making friends."
And then they left.
(Joey laughs)
I was like damn,
finally started getting some
good list of friends going
and they all just fucking left.
- Yeah.
- They just yeeted out.
- Can you imagine they
had their own problems?
(Garnt laughing)
- How dare they?
- I know.
- The audacity.
- The audacity to have nationalities aside
from the place I'm living
right at this moment.
- I have to ask because
you've seen our drift special,
who was the best drifter?
- You.
- And why was it me?
Thank you, thanks.
- I mean-
- Was that really the
question you needed to ask?
- I wanted to just make, I
want to feel good about myself
- You might as well just ask the question.
Alexi, can you just give
me a hand job right now?
- I just want to whip your
dick right out, right now.
- It's ready, come on.
- It's okay.
I already got his PayPal
email, so it's fine.
(all laughing)
- Slips him a 20. (chuckles)
Okay, I must admit,
even though we clowned
on you in the episode,
you clearly were the best drifter.
You just fucked up in the end.
- Yeah, I just fucked up in the end.
I mean, that test is bullshit.
It's fake news, I
clearly won the election.
- Well, you were the most
sort of confident with it
so you've got a bit too hectic with it.
That's why.
- Yeah.
- I would like to argue though,
that the starting position
was a little different.
Like you were clearly the most-
- That's your fault.
- I mean, you were the
most experienced driver.
- With the manual driver.
- Out of all of us.
- Well, like I said before, it's,
you all got to, like I watched the video
and I thought, "Hey, that's about right."
Like from what I've seen,
it wasn't really different.
Like if you haven't driven,
like the prerequisite for learning how to,
maybe learn how to ski,
the prerequisite is
being able to stand up.
If you can't stand up,
then you're not gonna be able to do it.
So if you're not used
to driving a manual car
for such a long time.
Also those cars have a
clutch, which is kind of-
- That clutch was weird.
- Well, their design,
was it making it like a
rattling sound when you hit it?
- Yeah.
- And also I feel like
a normal clutch like,
if I touch it a slight,
I feel it in the car.
This one, I had to fucking slam it down
to get anything out of it.
- So the clutches in those,
'cause you're constantly slipping them.
- Fucking it.
- Yeah, so the clutches are made
to take a lot of heat and also-
- Makes sense.
- Be kind of grippy so
they're not easy to drive.
So they're definitely not easy to drive.
Even though the car looks fairly,
didn't look too extreme.
Yeah, they're kind of a pain in the ass.
Look, even I do that.
I left my Mark II at the
tuner shop like last week,
and he lent me his drift car,
one of his personal drift
cars, just as the courtesy car.
What, this?
He's like "Yeah, I got too many of them,
just take that one."
- I got too many.
- Too much in the way.
And I stalled it twice
before leaving the car park
and he's like, "Alexi, you suck."
I'm like, "Yeah, whatever, man."
'Cause everyone knows,
it's always hard to jump
into someone else's car.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm just like only two? Damn.
(all laughing)
I stalled like eight times
trying to move forward.
- It was all right.
You all did good it was-
- You would be able to
drive a normal manual car
because even for me, I stalled it a lot
and I've like, I'd gotten used to it,
but the biting point is like so small.
It feels like you're gonna
break the car as well.
And you go like one millimeter above
and it just stalls.
Like there's no leeway at all.
- Yeah.
- They're a little bit tricky,
but you'll did pretty good.
It was an enjoyable video
and even I enjoyed
watching the whole thing.
- Oh that's good.
- That's a W.
I wonder how, because we
obviously didn't get to go on
the serious track or anything, right?
How do you transition
from just doing your little fucking donuts
to like actually going on a track,
because there has to be something like,
how do you-
- Is there like a test?
- How do you in between that?
Because how do you learn?
Because it seemed like
there wasn't really a way.
Like, it was...
- It's just a slow progression of,
like there is a little bit
of a sort of a wax on wax off
approach to it where it's
like, you do the donuts,
then you did the handbrake turn,
like the parking, but then what you do is,
you do the handbrake turn,
but then you transition to doing a donut.
Then that's a drift.
You didn't get to that point.
That's okay.
Normally it takes people a bit longer
if you haven't done any sort
of car stuff before like that.
So it's just a slow progression.
Like you start off going slower,
then you build a bit of speed.
Then you get a bit too overconfident
and you spin out a lot.
Then you start to, "Okay,
let's dial it back a bit."
And it's just slowly, slowly building up.
It's kind of like, what I've noticed is,
so I used to play video games,
like "Quake Arena" and stuff like that,
boomer stuff back in the day.
But then I gave it up for a long time.
Never played shooters.
And then all this whole
BR thing started up again.
And I thought, "Oh,
this is actually cool."
Like a lot of people,
you're paying real people.
It wasn't like CES, I didn't
mean to get into that.
And I started, I noticed that like,
watching people, you
know, pros playing again,
is that they just sort of jump in.
It's like first games a dud.
It's like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because they'd just been
doing it for so long.
Whereas I noticed that like,
if I get in, it's like the
first two or three games,
it's like, yeah, my aims
off, I'm terrible, I suck.
Same thing with drifting, you start off.
It's like, you got to like
recalibrate everything
and it just gets better and better.
And the better you get,
the faster you can hit
corners really well.
Compared to when you're a beginner.
Like it might take until
the end of the day.
You finally get that corner right.
I entered at a good speed,
the car didn't go too sideways,
I kept my speed up, yeah!
And you get that huge rush.
And then you get that again
and again and again again.
And honestly it doesn't...
The rush doesn't get any worse.
It doesn't get any lower.
You just end up going faster,
more angle, you know, more, more speed-
- Power.
- More power.
- The orgasm just gets more intense.
- [Alexi] It does.
- You're really selling me on this.
Okay, how long would you
say it takes from like,
coming from nothing to kind of going on,
like one of the tracks that
isn't like the practice track?
- You can do it straight away.
Like they have other tracks
which are kind of smaller,
but I'd say I've been drifting, let's see,
for like 20 years.
- God damn.
- And I'm pretty confident,
like I could probably,
I've never actually driven
like a top-level car before.
I'm pretty confident that
if you'd give me a few laps,
I'd be okay at it.
Like, I'm not a top level driver.
I've got the...
I hold the second highest,
but I've got like a
diamond license, sort of.
I'm like a diamond tank driver.
(laughing)
- Not challenger yet.
Just grinding to get master or challenger.
- I'm not at that level yet.
I haven't done (indistinct)
for a long time.
But I can confidently drive
pretty much any track.
That's been 20 years.
If you, it depends on you
but if you drifted every,
if you drifted a two
or three times a week,
like, say you go to Ebisu,
you went there two or three times a week.
It would maybe take you two weeks or so
to be pretty confident most of the tracks.
Depending if you crashed or not.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- The crash is definitely like this.
- Crashes are-
- Those fuck people's heads, right?
When they, like as in their
mental towards like drifting,
if they crash, some people.
- Yeah some people, I've
seen people quit drifting.
I've seen people quit, it's
like they'll blow their engine
or they'll crash, and they're like-
- I'm done.
- Yeah, I'm done.
- Yeah.
- I've seen one guy actually
sell his car at the track
to another guy, like a
guy had a truck there
with an empty truck.
He's like, "What do you wanna do with it?
You want me to tow you back to where."
He's like, "Man, I just want to sell it."
So the guy, he was a dealer.
He's a car dealer.
He's like, "Yeah I'll buy it, here's cash,
I'll buy it from you."
- Okay.
- The ultimate rage quit.
(Garnt laughs)
- So, yeah, people just give up,
'cause it's a huge, like, once
you crash a car, then it's-
- It's a big like decision point.
- Yeah, it's like,
it can cost like several
thousand dollars even
to get it back to.
And it's a crashed car now,
it's not perfect anymore.
It's not good.
From that crash, you might have
all sorts of things happen.
So yeah, it could be really expensive.
Some crashes you can be lucky,
it's just the bumper,
other ones it's like,
you bend the whole frame
and the whole car is a write off
and it's just parts now.
- Jesus.
- Sounds like a double edged sword, right?
- Can't wait.
- It's a gamble. It is a gamble.
Like I recently set up a simulator rig,
which I'm hoping to use
more on my Twitch streams,
just to get more sort of
seat virtual seat time.
Like it's not as good as the real thing,
but it's still pretty good.
Like it's just-
- Do you have like the steering wheel?
- Yeah, I got the steering
wheel, I got foot pedals,
the little seat in the rack
and everything that goes on.
Yeah, it's good.
It's at a stage now where you can use it
as a fairly good facsimile
of the real thing.
Not so much as the feeling,
but just the concentration mindset.
- Like a combination of movements?
- Yeah, yeah.
You can practice your...
'Cause you know that like
there's your tracks IRL
and there's tracks in-game.
So I can watch the
video of me at the track
and then go in the simulator and go,
okay, I keep doing this here.
I got to unlearn that
because then you just hit
the reset button back to start,
back to start, screw it up.
Okay, back to start, let's try it again.
Okay, got it.
And you just get that mindset.
- Now, that's the future, isn't it?
- I mean, it's kind of like,
it's like a speed run.
(laughs)
If you think about it, you know like-
- All drifting in future
will be done virtually.
- Dude, there are entire virtual drifting-
- I've seen.
- Drifting competitions
and they're serious, man.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah I went in the comp once,
I just went in sort of as a joke
and I just made a huge ass out of myself.
I crashed off the start line.
(all laughing)
Yeah, it's serious.
- How do the virtual ones
compare to actually doing
the real thing though?
- In the sense of what they do in there,
it's like almost the same.
- Oh wow.
- With the way they drive,
I mean even like there's
things like iRacing
and stuff where it's like a,
it's a full on NASCAR race
and it's run at like the
same sort of schedule
as the real thing.
But it's just not real.
So here's the thing though,
some drivers who are
really good in the game,
have tried doing an IRL
and they're just like,
I can't do it.
It's just too, it's too scary.
- There's a lot more forces at play.
- Yeah.
- Like the G-Forces.
Also the fact that you could die.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You can crash and get hurt.
Like at Ebisu, like I said
before, I saw a guy come off
the track, hit the wall,
like at an oblique angle.
- Was he okay?
- No, he broke his leg and his ribs.
- Yikes.
- I'd rather that than a
fucking sticker on my car.
(all laughing)
I'll tell you that.
- Which wins?
A broken leg or one sticky boy?
- Do you know those fucking stickers
that do not peel off as well.
Those are my fucking nightmare.
It's like industrial glue stickers.
Don't fucking come, sorry.
- Are we still on the sticker talks?
- It's in my head now.
- That was like half an hour ago.
And you're like-
- You never forget it.
- Recurring nightmares.
- I can't just forget my fear
like that, are you kidding me?
Man.
So how often do you stream on Twitch?
- Oh, God.Don't ask my subs.
They're very angry.
I used to do a lot more regularly,
but then when the rona happened,
I thought like everyone else did,
"Oh, this free time, yeah.
I can get back into it properly."
No.
- Yeah, that's never happens.
- It just made it even worse.
My aim is like twice a week.
I want to do some more
like SIM stuff, also IRL.
My next goal is to do a full
track day as an IRL stream.
- What is your Twitch?
- I've sort of, what's that?
- Unfortunately, it's NORIYAROJAPAN.
- NORIYAROJAPAN.
- Check him out, check him out.
- Add that on the end there.
But it's mostly car related stuff.
Like either car games,
like "My Summer Car"
or other sorts of indie games
and stuff like that.
But I also want to do more IRL
stuff now that all this sort
of stuff has started calming down.
Track days are running again.
I want to get the backpack
and all that sort of stuff
and do a full track-
- I think that would do really well.
- Yeah, that'd be something.
- All of my, if you look at the...
If you saw my highlights,
like all the biggest highlights are-
- IRL stuff, yeah.
- The best thing about that is like,
it's you don't know what's gonna happen.
- [Hosts] Yeah.
- I can crash it every corner.
(laughing)
- They're all waiting.
Crash, crash.
- But then sometimes
something really cool happens.
Like, I think I was in a car actually
with Suenaga, the guy
you rode with at Ebisu,
I was riding passenger
and he got like within
a millimeter of the car in front,
we're doing like forth gear,
and chat is just going nuts.
- Pog!
- Was he just like laughing,
like he always does?
- Yeah, he just like (laughs).
- I love that guy.
Just his laugh, it's
just so like emotionless
and yet so maniacal, I fucking love it.
- I've never seen a
handbrake move like that.
It was like pumping it up.
And I was like, what
the fuck is happening?
It was insane.
The man was insane.
Absolute legend.
- I remember when we were like
learning the handbrake turns
and just like that one
session gave me like
the fucking worst wankers cramp
I've ever liked felt in my life.
It's going ugh.
- Wankers cramp?
I have never heard of this word.
- Because that's the same
kind of movement, right?
- God, God.
Where is your dick?
- Down in your leg.
- Cranking it up, like Jesus.
- No, because I've never had
to crank it like that hard.
And it just was a movement on
my arms weren't used to, man.
What can I say?
- Oh my God.
- It was fun as hell.
- That's a normal thing you do get.
Also you hurt your hand, right?
- Yeah.
- Let me tell you.
Okay, never put your thumbs
inside the steering wheel.
- That's I think that's
exactly what I was-
- He was scared to death.
So he was gripping.
- No, no, I guarantee you
that's what happened is because
what you do is you put your hand,
your thumb inside the steering wheel
and then when it counter steers,
the spoke of it comes down
and wangs you on the fingers.
That happens a lot.
- That's exactly like, now
that I'm thinking about it.
Like, if I was holding it like this,
where I injured myself is
exactly where that spoke was.
- They should have told you that.
- Come on Ebisu, what the fuck.
- I didn't think we were going fast enough
for it to fucking matter
to grip on to the thing.
I was like woo, you know, like...
- We're sorry that you're a natural.
- You were going slow.
You didn't have to hold on.
- I've never driven a manual.
Give me a fucking break, man!
- Where did you think the
car was gonna go Joey?
- I don't fucking know.
I was scared.
Anyway, anyway.
So yeah, it's been lovely to have you on.
- Thank you very much for coming on.
- Do you like to shout
out anything on your end?
- I have a YouTube channel, Noriyaro.
It's car stuff.
I do want to do more,
if there's more itasha shows
and I eventually want
to do Itasha as well.
- We gotta come on
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would love to see itasha show.
- Yeah, itasha festival.
- 100% I'll let you know.
Also, so this weekend I'm
going out to a track out in
the middle of the mountains
in Gunma, which is actually a,
it's actually an old school cycling track.
It's like a mountain road sort of thing,
but it's actually a drift,
they use it for drifting now.
- Rip cyclists.
- It's gonna be a sort of simulated,
Toga drifting and all these
cool guys that companies-
- How many cycles can we drift into?
- That's pretty cool.
And I've got a bunch of
other stuff coming up,
I don't know.
- All the social links-
- By the way, I bought a little present,
I see you have a lot of
things on the walls here.
So I brought a little...
- Aw, it's so cute.
- A little A86 from "Initial D."
- It's even for the (indistinct) thing.
- That's so cute.
- Put it over on the shelf somewhere.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
- That's so cute.
I love it.
- Look at all these beautiful patrons.
- And thank you very much to the patrons
for supporting us and also
supporting the drift episode
that we did.
It's all led up here.
And also like we've talked
about this from our perspective,
but if you ever get the
chance to try out drifting,
even if it's just being
driven around a track,
I highly recommend it.
As we've said, it is an adrenaline rush
like you've never felt before.
These guys have just turned
fucking three, right now.
- I don't wanna grow up.
- Wee!
- But yeah, if you'd
like to support the show,
make sure to go over to our Patreon.
Also check us out on our
subreddit and our Twitter.
And if you want to listen
to the show on audio,
then check us out on Spotify.
Links on the description.
- And you can follow this beautiful boy.
- Yes.
- Absolutely.
- Go check out all the
links to Noriyaro's stuff
down in the description below.
And thanks for coming on.
- Thank you very much for
having me, it's great.
It's been-
- Hope you've had a good time.
- Yeah, it was awesome.
- And with that said that's
everything for today.
We will see you guys next time.
- [All] Bye, bye.
(upbeat music)